foreign
I called to order the special committee
on the Family Division of the Circuit
Court of the State of New Hampshire it
is Tuesday May 16 2023.
previously I mentioned previous
iterations of looking at the court in
recent history you may recall a task
force on family law chaired by The
Honorable Henry P mock the task force
met between 2002 and 04 issuing a final
report on November 1st of that year the
task force had members of the
legislature drawn from the House and
Senate Judiciary committees and the
house children and family law committee
additional members came from various
stakeholder groups then we were reminded
of the 2012 house committee on redress
of grievances over two dozen cases were
looked at at some length recommendations
were made both in the area of changes in
procedure and towards specific
individuals
when I discovered this past weekend and
doing some office cleaning was a page
describing the family court Forum held
on May 25th of 2016 at the upper Walker
house
I recall this meeting because I was
there
individuals were allowed to speak for a
maximum of three minutes having
previously been coached as to their
conduct for the speech by representative
then representative Kimberly rice The
Forum was moderated by then
representative and now Commissioner of
Education Frank edelblue
among the directions as to content of
speeches was this paragraph
this is not and it was in bold face
italics a forum for adjudication
details of specific cases will not be
addressed use of specific names of
people should not be used simply State
the judge or the clerk or whatever
appropriate title applies interestingly
that's kind of the way I got this
committee going maybe that was in the
back of my mind
additionally participants were told
individuals are encouraged to submit
written testimony if they believe three
minutes is not enough time in such case
use the three minutes to give the
highlights of the written testimony and
finally the document from then reads
individuals speaking are encouraged to
share ideas and observations about how
the family court system
has worked well for them or where there
are opportunities for improvement
so I mentioned this at some length
because this has not been mentioned as
we looked at recent history
of the previous times When leaders
gathered to hear from the public the way
we are functioning here is much more
similar to this 2016 iteration than the
two that came before it with a couple of
exceptions while we do not have
stakeholder groups among the committee
members as the first one did we are
affording them times to make
presentations
and secondly we are offering five
minutes to speak not free
calendar we will meet once again next
week May 23rd we will not meet the week
after that which is the day after
Memorial Day we will meet again here on
Tuesdays June 6 20 and 27 before
breaking for the summer
today we're going to hear from the New
Hampshire Bar Association and then from
the New Hampshire legal assistance on
June 6 we hope to hear from the director
of Child Support Services we have others
who are finalizing their slots with us
for the 20th and 27th of June
June 13th is a court visiting day it is
still being worked out but we hope to
have three different Family Court venues
around the state ready to receive us
it is possible that one or more of them
might choose to give a tour before the
actual hearings of the day commence
we hope to know the locations by next
week so members of the committee perhaps
could sign up which one they wish to go
to lest we all wind up in one place
committee researcher Christina Daya has
been working on a few projects for us
one is on the subject of shared
parenting how to various States view
this the other is on RSA 458c child
support guidelines and its legislative
history
and yesterday I asked if she could look
to see if there was any report from that
meeting of six seven years ago at upper
Walker if there is we'll we'll find it
we'll make it known yeah
once again it has been suggested to me
that I read the notice and disclaimer
before we begin our work today
the special committee on the Family
Division of the Circuit Court was formed
to investigate a allegations of
irregularities including failure to
follow or enforce statutes
unwarranted waiver of or failure to
follow court rules
delay in rendering decisions denial of
due process and other procedural issues
the committee will conduct hearings
relative to the process of the Family
Division of the circuit court and may
make recommendations for future
legislation
the purpose of the committee is to
discover areas where changes in
procedure or changes in the law
regarding the Family Division of the
Circuit Court might be made
the purpose of this special committee is
not to retry the cases of citizens who
disagree with the outcome of litigation
members of the public will be given the
opportunity to testify and present
information to the committee because of
the number of people who may wish to
testify there may be a time limit
imposed on each person testifying which
is permissible under house world 100.
appropriate subject matter for
testifying will be limited to specific
instances of where there seem to be
irregularastifying about subject matter
related to a court case or who submit
documentation related to a court case
should know that both will be made part
of the public record
therefore subject matter that is either
confidential or may be under seal should
not be discussed or submitted to the
committee as disclosure of such matters
would be a violation of Statute or of a
court order
the committee reserves the right not to
accept written or oral testimony or
materials which would in its judgment
violate the foregoing
so with our little opening boilerplates
we
first
calling upon
I believe it's the New Hampshire Bar
Association is that right
and there's one rule that everyone's
sitting at that table has to observe
please turn on the microphone
and you know you've done it well because
the red light comes on thank you thank
you
chairman Pearson and distinguish
ing members my name is
chandelaris I was contacted by the New
Hampshire Bar Association to testify
about my experience as a family law
practitioner and as a member of the New
Hampshire bar association's family law
section I appreciate the very much the
opportunity to talk with you today I
have been a practicing family law
attorney for just about 30 years and I'm
here to provide you with my perspective
and my understanding as a practitioner
working in the court system for a very
long time
just by way of some background about
myself I am one of the founders and
partners in my firm Channel Harrison
shirk which is located in Nashua my firm
has been operating for 23 years and we
practice exclusively family law which
includes things like divorce child
support matters guardianship of minors
and parenting cases prior to my work at
my firm I was the chief staff attorney
at the New Hampshire Department of
Health and Human Services for their
division of child support services I am
also a governor at large on the New
Hampshire bar association's Board of
Governors
and lastly I'm finishing my term as one
of the directors on the board of
directors for 603 legal aid which you
know is the legal services organization
that provides legal representation and
education to qualifying low-income
people and prior to 603 legal aid which
was established two years ago one of its
predecessor organizations was the pro
bono referral system which I was a board
member on that Organization for about 20
years
and lastly I was appointed by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court as a
commissioner on its access to Justice
Commission and I've been on that
commission since 2007. I have experience
both in working in court and working
with families as well as being involved
with some of these stakeholder
organizations and I'm hopefully going to
provide you with some information and
some resources that may be of assistance
to the committee you know I know as
representative Pearson mentioned and one
of the purposes of the committee is to
investigate some irregularities and it
seems like perhaps some of the
complaints that have come from the
public involve some of the court rules
and the Rules of Evidence
some of the self-represented litigants
as well as some of us attorneys
sometimes have difficulties with
application of those rules to their
particular case type or the particular
facts of their case so I wanted to give
the committee some examples today so for
example the Family Division circuit
court has a rule it's Rule 1.28 and it
involves what's called an offer of proof
and an offer of proof that court is a
statement or a representation made by an
attorney or a presentation yes sir
we're going to have this in written form
I can submit it afterwards I'd really
appreciate if we could get 11 copies of
this because I write pretty fast but
you're really making some good Forward
Motion here and let me know if I'm
speaking too quickly I've accused of
that um a few times in my life I would
attest
um so the Family Division rule 1.28
involves these offers of proof and it
involves presentations not testimony but
presentations made by an attorney or
made by a litigant who is representing
himself or herself at court so for
example that specific Court rule says
that the court can exercise its
discretion when receiving evidence
through an offer of proof
one thing that the rule also says is
that if an attorney or a
self-represented person is going to make
a presentation about something that a
another witness would testify to
or something that a document they want
to present that was drafted by a third
person that third person or witness must
be in the courtroom and the court pretty
rigidly adheres to that rule so for
example lots of times my clients want to
give me copies of Facebook page or
printed out text messages that somebody
else sent them this Court rule would
require that whoever's Facebook page
that document came from or whoever's
printed out text messages came from they
would need to be sitting in the
courtroom and there's a good reason for
that prior to this rule being initiated
attorneys and self-represented litigants
could submit whatever documents they
want affidavits signed by family members
affidavits signed by other Witnesses but
that person did not need to be in the
courtroom well now the Court rule says
You must be there in order so the other
side the respondent could cross-examine
and that witness about that piece of
evidence you want to submit so it is one
rule that the court is very stringent
about
sometimes depending on the record if
it's for example a police report or a
hospital record maybe the judge uses his
or her discretion to say I don't need
that person in the courtroom it's an
official record by the police department
or it's an official record by you know
the hospital
sometimes records are not submitted for
the reason they exist so for example if
I wanted to submit a record somebody's
Hospital record maybe I don't want the
judge to use that record in order to
show what happened at the hospital I
want that record to show the date that
they were in the hospital because
somebody might say well you weren't at
your work that day and I would say to
the judge look here's the record that
shows they were at the hospital but I
don't need that record to show what
actually happened at the hospital so
this rule says that the per if you're
going to make a representation by a
third party or a third party record they
need to be in the court room in order to
have them cross-examine
um
The Rules of Evidence oh sorry there's
also enough could we stop for a minute
here for a question
thank you chairman Pearson and thank you
for taking my question I just wanted to
clarify so if it's a text message or a
Facebook post would it just be the
person that was you know screenshotting
such evidence that would need to be
there like so say somebody had sent me a
text message would it just need to be me
that was in the courtroom are you saying
that also the person who wrote me the
text message would need me to the
important she wanted to clarify no
that's a great question it's a good
distinction so if somebody sent it to
you they would not have to be there
because you could testify yourself that
you received that text message it's if
you want to send someone else's text
message or someone else's Facebook page
or a document that the school nurse
wrote or a teacher wrote a third person
other than yourself having that
experience
you're welcome
um there also are the is a Court rule
and and again I'm just going to give you
the number it is Rule
2.19 and that particular Court rule says
that prior to an initial Hearing in a
family court matter that evidence
proposed orders
Financial affidavits must be submitted
seven days ahead of time
and the judges are very strictly
adhering to that rule so for example I
can tell you I had my own experience of
I submitted documents six days before a
hearing and the other attorney was upset
that he didn't have them seven days
ahead of time and the court continued
the hearing with good reason so that
people can have time to look and vet the
information so oftentimes when people
are representing themselves they're not
realizing that they have these rules
that they have to comply with and when
they get to court sometimes the judges
are denying them submitting their
evidence and documents because they
haven't followed the Court rule to
submit them seven days ahead of time
um The Rules of Evidence
as this committee may know do not have
technically strict
application in family law cases the
rules are applied on a limited basis
some particular case types like domestic
violence there is a particular rule that
says that the Rules of Evidence don't
apply I do not do a lot of domestic
violence work but I'm aware of that rule
there are New Hampshire Supreme Court
cases going back decades to the 1950s or
earlier that talk about holding that the
Rules of Evidence don't have a strict
application in these type of family law
cases
and despite that rule that the Rules of
Evidence are not rigidly applied the
court does follow two rules rather
strenuously
first is the rule of relevance something
has to be relevant to the case
or relevant to the facts and the second
rule is hearsay and as I just talked
about that rule 1.28 when you make an
offer of proof or you're going to talk
about something else somebody said that
person has to be in the courtroom
I have not personally seen the courts
avoid following the court rules
it's my experience that the court
applies the rules evenly to both
attorneys and non-attorney litigants
and the rules obviously are applied very
factually to the case and they're
applied depending on the case type and
there's a good reason for that the
reason that in my opinion the court
rules can't be uh sorry the Rules of
Evidence can't be rigidly applied it's
because the court
has to be able to weigh that evidence as
the finder of fact they have to be able
to give appropriate weight to a
particular piece of evidence like I
talked about maybe I don't want the
hospital record to be submitted into
evidence for the actual what happened at
the hospital maybe I want to use the
date and so the judge is permitted under
the court rules to give the appropriate
weight to certain pieces of evidence to
certain testimony and documents for
example to make a ruling that's in the
best interest of a child or a victim of
domestic violence
there are also lots of statutes that
sort of give the court this discretion
as well one of them that I can think of
in particular is RSA
461-a colon six
and it's the best interest standard
um for a child
and it provides a list of what the court
can consider when determining what's in
a child's best interest so to interrupt
you it's not completely arbitrary the
best interests of the child is not a go
for it judge there are some parameters
set out in 461. absolutely thank you
absolutely
um and as I'm talking about the Rules of
Evidence
Port rules you know for example maybe
someone's making an argument in court
that a child's home is inappropriate and
someone wants to submit photographs of
the home to show that it is appropriate
or that it's fine but that particular
statute has a list of things that the
court needs to consider and this is why
um
at least I and maybe others in the
committee have been told by
people high up in the Judiciary that
we we as the legislature not only have
the right but may have the specific
interest to to work on some of those
parameters as we perhaps may see as best
that pertain to family law cases too
voluminous for me to talk about I know
you all are aware of but to me there's
three main statutes that that this
committee may want to take a look at or
you know self-represented um people who
go to court the three main statutes in
my mind are RSA
461-a which is the parenting statute
RSA 458 which is the divorce law statute
and also applies to unwed
um parents and RSA 458-c which is the
child support statute
and in talking about all these rules
um the committee may know that there's
been a weighted case study by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court that showed the
need for 32 more clerical staff and 18
more judges in all of the circuit courts
including Family Division I did a little
bit of research and it was actually
astounding to me that on the court
website
um in 2022
there were over 15
600 new cases filed in just the Family
Division and when I say new cases I mean
cases that are not reopened not
modification cases not modifying and
existing parenting plan or not modifying
child support of those cases over 7 000
cases were divorce and parenting cases
new cases on average that's
587 cases new cases per month and there
were over 3 800 domestic violence cases
alone that's 321 new domestic violent
cases not extension of the domestic
violence or um or anything else that had
to do with filing again in a case brand
new cases which year 2022 thank you
in my experience
the lack of delay or the lack of
consistency relates to there's not
enough judges and equally important
there's not enough clerical staff
because of my length of time in working
in the court system in the olden days
I'll call it I remember going to court
where Court would start at nine o'clock
and then at 12 o'clock there would be a
break and then Court would start again
at 1 30 and everybody knew that but it's
not
um unusual
for court cases now to start at 8 A.M
right when the doors open It's Not
Unusual and I have been involved in
divorce trials where the judge will say
we're going to work through lunch
because I've got two other ex parte
hearings I need to hear after this
um I hear and talk with judges that tell
me that they're working on nights in
weekends to draft their orders and I
never 15 years ago would hear of those
kind of things
as important as I mentioned is when the
judges make those orders now there's not
enough Court staff to process those
orders so the court tries very hard it's
my understanding
um and again I don't intend to be an
expert about court process
um at the clerk's office but it's my
understanding the courts work really
hard to get orders out within 30 days
and sometimes it's not possible because
there's just a lack of court court staff
during covid and I don't know if it's
still consistent now at one point the
court was down 30 percent in the clerk's
office that's huge
um they don't the judges don't have
enough writing time because every second
of their day is packed with hearing
cases for example if I have a divorce
trial starting at 9 00 a.m oftentimes
I'll get there and the bailiff will say
sit outside the courtroom the judge has
to hear an ex parte an emergency hearing
or there's a domestic violence case that
got filed and now my trial doesn't start
till 10 o'clock and my clients lose that
time as well well because now we've lost
an hour just because there was an
emergency that nobody could anticipate
or nothing could happen
um
again I don't intend to be an expert on
the court process but for example every
time a domestic violence case is filed
the it is filed by the victim the court
has to stop what it's doing to manage
that case so for example in the already
scheduled day of the judge now they have
to read that petition or perhaps talk
with the victim before they issue an ex
parte order once the judge issues that
order the order goes down to the clerk's
office and the clerks have to stop what
they're working on in order to process
that and when I say process they have to
enter that domestic violence order into
several databases as I understand it
including the National Crime information
center and other New Hampshire
Registries
they have to issue an order to the
defendant they have to contact the
sheriff to serve that order they have to
schedule a hearing within 30 days as the
mandates of the domestic violence law
state
the defendant can request a hearing in
five days so now if they had a hearing
scheduled and the defendant wants to
request a sooner hearing they have to
squish that hearing into a five-day
window because of the statute so you can
see that there's an overlay of the
Court's day is scheduled and then some
emergencies sometimes happen which cause
also further delays
and of course the divorce and parenting
cases and the child support cases and
the guardianship cases they all have the
same requirements of scheduling notices
and notifying the respondent and
scheduling a hearing
um
I have been in court for example
recently to schedule final hearings and
the judges are saying we don't have any
days at all to schedule until the end of
the year or the beginning of next year
so having judges in the court staff and
I know it's an issue of money but it's
important to keep the process going with
the correct amount of judges and Court
staff to deal with that I want the
committee to know there are a number of
helpful reports in data and perhaps you
already do know that on the New
Hampshire judicial branch website the
reports are broken down by the courts
they're broken down sometimes by the
cases in case types so that's a really
helpful resource
um and I know chairman Pearson you
wanted to keep this committee positive
um and there's so many members of the
public who who need resources and
there's things that they can do to
educate themselves and get this
information so I want to talk a little
bit about
um some underutilized resources from my
perspective you know there's a lot of
barriers to the access to justice but
there also are a lot of underutilized
resources that I think can help so again
the court website is terrific
there is a link on the court website
that's called self-help and on that link
members of the public and attorneys
because I use them too we can find
videos about what to expect at court how
to file a domestic violence case how to
file your divorce case
um information about first appearance
which is an informational session for
parents with children under the age of
18. there are checklists there are links
to the court rules to the law library
both the state law library and the
Franklin Pierce UNH School of Law
Library Lawyer Referral Services legal
aid and most importantly all the court
forms I printed out just for myself
because I wanted to take a look at it
for example if you wanted to see a
checklist about how to file a divorce it
literally starts with some things to
consider there's a section that says
here's all the forms you need
the filing fee
what will happen next what you need to
do at court and there's multiple
checklists one page checklist that look
like this that can help members of the
public figure out how to file their case
and it's super helpful
there's also
um
you know the court rules I know they're
long but they are very easy to
understand and very chronological about
how a case works and so I always
encourage people to take a look at that
um
it's a bar association website is also a
really great source of information
it also talks about its Referral
Services
has multiple links to the court rules
and the laws there's one service that
the New Hampshire Bar Association has
worked with the American Bar Association
it's called free legal answers and it is
a really great project with the American
Bar Association and their goal is to
have this in all 50 states and New
Hampshire started it a number of years
ago where people who qualify income wise
can ask a any legal question they want
about process about their case they can
provide they can scan in documents and
New Hampshire attorneys will answer that
question for free
I do it myself it's great because you
can log on to that website 24 hours a
day and answer anyone's question there's
lots of questions on there family law
questions landlord tenant questions and
New Hampshire and Bar Association
attorneys go on that website and answer
those questions for those clients we
provide them with links to forms or
websites to take a look at so that is a
really good program the bar association
also
has a program called lawline
lawline is a on the second Wednesday
of every month from 6 to 8 pm and
members of the public can call in New
Hampshire attorneys answer the phone and
answer their questions for free
um law firms do it as a project
individual lawyers do it and so people
volunteer to answer these questions and
it's it's just it's a benefit that the
bar association provides the bar
association also has lots of links on
its website for the public related to
Law related educational programs and
Publications that I think can help
people
and while I'm not here to speak on
behalf of the access to Justice
Commission I am aware of some of their
initiatives obviously because of my
membership and on the commission and I
wanted to just talk briefly about some
of those initiatives that the access to
Justice Commission is working on for
example the commission has worked on a
pilot project which has started already
called Court Navigators there's one
Navigator in Nashua in the Circuit Court
in Nashua there's another navigator that
floats around to the other circuit
courts and again it's a pilot project
and those Court Navigators assist the
public in how to file their cases and
answering questions about the court
system the access to Justice Commission
has also received
the American Rescue plan act or arper
funding in 2021 over 1.1 million dollars
to work on various projects to help
access the Justice including expanding
the Navigator program as well as
educating what we're going to call
public Navigators members of the public
who might want to volunteer to be a
navigator to help people
the other projects that the initiative
are working on is simplifying and
translating court forms there are a lot
of people who have a barrier to Justice
because of their language barriers so
we're working on that we're going to
expand the Navigator program there's
some initiatives for alternative dispute
resolution
there's going to be a portal for the
legal Navigators and a virtual Court
Center and then the commission is also
going to collect some data to measure
its impacts and success on these
projects
the access to justice has its own
current task force that deal with having
the members of the public have attorney
access
or assisting those with disability
and so
um the commission also um and I have
been personally involved in a pilot
program
um to help work with public libraries
the commission probably knows that a lot
of members of the public seek out the
libraries for not just their computers
um in the internet but actually talk to
the Librarians and ask them for
information about how to deal with their
cases so we're working on a project to
educate those Librarians and doing
public presentations to do things like
how do you draft a will how do you file
your small claims case things like that
so there's a lot of great projects that
the access to Justice Commission is
working on
you can also as a committee go on to the
access to Justice website which is part
of the judicial branch website and see
their reports for civil legal needs in
New Hampshire you can also see their
annual reports which are listed there
and there's just so many projects that
they're working on at two voluminous to
discuss here but those reports are
really helpful
I'm sure the committee has heard
previous testimony that 80 percent
of every family law case in the circuit
court has at least
one self-represented individual if not
two self-represented individuals on a
Case
um and the law in the domestic violence
uh sorry Domestic Relations area is
complex you know for example
self-represented litigants are expected
to draft their decree of divorce about
how to divide their retirement accounts
and I work as a consultant for some
other attorneys to draft those special
documents to divide retirement accounts
in their complex
but there are a lot of stakeholders in
New Hampshire working really hard to
help those people who want to represent
themselves or who need to represent
themselves and I know I've only skimmed
the tip of the iceberg this morning so
I'm happy to answer any questions that
anyone asked
we're going to take a breath first
this was incredible thank you
representative Greg you'll go first
because Mr chairman
get a pass thank you so much this has
been super informative I really
appreciate it so in the area of domestic
violence which has got more
complications than I think we have
people in the state
um is there a particular resource that's
available for pro-say litigants and that
I know that's even more complicated when
it's Pro Se given the Dynamics of that
but for both sides like where um what
are the resources really for them is it
the bar association or it's a really
good question thank you for that
question representative
um to me the number one resource is a
project called the dove project d-o-v-e
from the New Hampshire Bar Association
and they help victims of domestic
violence connect up with an attorney and
they do that quickly and I'm really
happy to say that there are a lot of New
Hampshire attorneys that take those
cases if a case is scheduled within five
days I mean sometimes you have very
little time to prepare as an attorney or
as a litigant to go to that case so
that's number one people can also go to
places like um the YWCA there's places
like um in Nashua for example Bridges
which is a place that helps domestic
violence victims but I would always
recommend that they call the New
Hampshire Bar Association that Dove
project they work very quickly and try
to find people in attorney very fast
it's difficult in domestic violence
cases because again I don't practice
them very often at all but
victims are limited to what they say in
their petition so it's really important
when they draft that petition to make
sure that they have all the facts that
they want to say in there otherwise
they're precluded by the court rules and
the domestic violence protocols from
talking about things outside the scope
of their petition so it's helpful if
even if they could just meet with an
attorney to help them craft their
petition it would help them a lot
fantastic thank you so much you're
welcome
representative long
thank you Mr chairman thank you this is
very helpful uh with respect to uh the
submission of evidence seven days is
that calendar days or calendar days it
is calendar days yeah obviously if it
falls on a weekend then it goes to that
Monday yes
Okay so
so
uh follow-up I may if it was a um so if
it's Friday
Saturday and Sunday is two days
if it's a fried if it's the seventh day
is on a Friday it would be due on a
Friday but let's say that day seven was
on Saturday then it would go to the
Monday yes very good thank you
representative Smith
thank you very much
um we're all exhausted I assume you are
also because it was an incredible
presentation
um
in New Hampshire
in order to practice law
um
you must be a member of the Bar
Association
yes
and if
and that differs
in other states is that not true
it does differ and I I wish I could
answer your question about how many
states require Bar Association
um
uh that people uh join their Bar
Association the number of states where
it is mandatory not just New Hampshire
uh if I could just follow up
um
in that case if I wanted to be
casual about it I would say that the bar
association in effect becomes a wholly
owned subsidiary of the court system
um
does that relationship
potentially interfere in any way with
not individual attorneys but the
association
being able to
challenge or question court procedures
so the bar association was created by
the New Hampshire Supreme Court
um and I I can't remember the year I
should know that year but I believe it
was in the 1970s so we are a creation of
the New Hampshire Supreme Court
um the bar association has its own
bylaws it has its own rules and it has
its own way to function even though we
were created by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court so I believe that the bar
association has a good relationship with
the court system But to answer your
question can the bar association
challenge or request changes to the
court rules
the answer is yes
representative Macbeth
welcome to allergy season thank you for
taking my question
I'm wondering if you care to comment on
we've had testimony from prosely
litigants
[Music]
concerned about their
orders being fair and
a lot of ways that maybe arguments that
that could have been presented to make
those orders more fair I'm wondering is
it the judge's responsibility to come up
with arguments
for peruse litigants or is that
something that say litiken is just
accepting that they
may not
have the full opportunity for all the
laws to be applied to their case if they
don't bring it forward I appreciate your
question thank you one thing that I do
as an attorney and I think I have a lot
of clients that will come to see me and
they they want to represent themselves
in court but they come to me just
looking for some advice the one thing
that I think is very very important is
having your proposed orders ready seven
days before a hearing and when I prepare
myself I go through those forms and say
okay I need to talk about parenting or
the parenting schedule or I need to talk
about health insurance and a divorce all
right so if a self-represented person
would go through those proposed orders
and and just make a list of everything
they actually wanted to talk about
because I know it's daunting it's
nerve-wracking when you're in court and
representing yourself and trying to
remember everything but just being able
to go over what proposals you might be
requesting of the judge will help bring
those to the judge's attention I would
also say that when people are
self-represented I have seen the judges
often ask them some questions to bring
out the information
it's not the judge's place in my opinion
to make the arguments for the person but
they will ask the questions that the
court needs to hear the answers to in
order to make those orders
um and so it's that's sort of my two two
place answer to to basically say having
your proposals ready for court is really
helpful because it gets your mind in a
place of what you need to discuss and
then the judge will sometimes ask those
questions to bring out the answers
when I thought it would be a good idea
to print out the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence
little did I realize
but there's uh I don't know if it's
Cliff Notes but it is New Hampshire
Rules of Evidence uh they're listing
rule 100 103 1.2 1.28 which you spoke to
and 2.2
which I believe the person who prepared
this for me thinks uh perhaps correctly
this is specifically to family court is
there a longer document than this that
is specifically to family court
it's an excellent question uh chairman
so on the court website
the court rules are there with um which
is which is really great
um within a searchable index
and so there are general rules of the
circuit court that apply to all the
circuit court cases and then you can go
down into
um into the um the section that just
deals with the domestic relation rules
and they break them down juvenile cases
guardianship cases but yes you can see
just the rules specific to the family
court thank you I'm reading here rule
2.2 application of New Hampshire Rules
of Evidence the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence do not apply
to the actions
listed above however the court in its
discretion
May utilize the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence so far this seems to track with
what a lot of people are objecting to
they don't follow the rules of evidence
no they don't have to
but
it continues
the the discretion May utilize the New
Hampshire Rules of Evidence to enhance
predictability orderly fair and reliable
presentation of evidence so there does
seem to be some narrowing so those who
would think uh family court has has to
follow all of this are missing the point
but if in their opinion
the judge did not follow the rules of
evidence even though in the objector's
opinion
it would have enhanced the predictable
orderly fair and reliable presentation
maybe they have a beef
maybe they have a valid objection
would that be a fair narrowing of the
objections that are sometimes made that
a judge does not follow rules of
evidence
I I do
if the court pretty much always follows
the rules of relevance in hearsay
um and I've talked about that I think it
would be difficult for
the legislature to
to make us a a rule that says that the
Rules of Evidence in family law cases
must apply because I think that takes
away some of the discretion of the
judges to get to what might be in the
best interest of a child or get what
might be in the best interest of a
family sometimes people have to the
judge may have to look at a piece of
evidence that doesn't strictly adhere to
The Rules of Evidence in order to get to
um a decision including in domestic
violence cases where those hearings
happen so quickly and if we're going to
have every witness there or we're going
to comply with the rules that five-day
rule in order to have that domestic
violence victim be able to be entitled
to a hearing might not be able to be
adhered to so I appreciate that and I
understand that but in my experience I I
don't think the judges just take every
piece of evidence it has to be relevant
it has to follow that rule of hearsay
and it has to be related to either the
facts or the case at hand not just
something unrelated see this is where
I'm trying to help those who bring
testimony to narrow it because if it's
just some broad assertion they don't
follow the rules that is not helpful to
us it's not helpful to their cause
so if we can narrow narrow narrow to
those parameters you have spoken of and
then we are presented with documentation
that perhaps within those rules those
that parameter you gave it wasn't
followed then I want to see how
frequently is that is that something
somebody having a bad day did somebody
make a mistake which we all do or is
this more widespread and if it is then
what do we do because I think I agree
with you passing a law on this wouldn't
be the right way to fix the problem but
I don't know what the right way is and
you know chairman I would also take a
look at some of the New Hampshire
Supreme Court cases there are multiple
cases that talk about why the The Rules
of Evidence don't rigidly imply in
family law cases and as I mentioned
before some of them going back to the
1950s and those cases have been followed
over and over again by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court but some of the dicta and
some of the reason things in those cases
I think would be helpful for the
committee to to take a look at
I wonder if we could have some of those
found
that was a yes
thank you
after the 52 other projects I've dumped
on you
thank you
representative Smith
thank you this is again a slightly
different question
um for very understandable reasons
when our sessions move to the last part
of the morning and we hear from
individuals not people here representing
agencies or institutions
no one has come to say we think the
family court is absolutely fabulous
everyone who has come is someone who
feels that they were not treated justly
and
of course
the the individual on the other side in
their case is not here
so we are not an appellate court and we
know intention of being an appellate
court but it means that we might lose
our
um
ability to discern what really is
happening in Family Court
are we hearing from 50 percent of the
cases are we here or is what we're
hearing representing 50 of the cases or
25 or 10 or 5
um
we have no way of knowing that
in your experience
in the court
um
can you help give us some
perception
of what actually is happening
overwhelmingly in the court in no way
minimizing the pain and anguish that
individuals feel
thank you for your question
um
family court cases are of course some of
the most difficult you know and I have
been involved in a lot of difficult
cases parents that are doing the best
for their kids parents that are you know
struggling with alcohol abuse or drug
abuse
um one thing that I think the court has
done which has been really helpful over
the the last oh gosh I don't know it's
changed a lot early on in my career the
court might make an order where somebody
files a motion and that motion the the
court order might just come back with
the word denied no explanation no
discussion about what happened the
courts try really hard now to make very
detailed orders they refer to the
statute that they looked at
um sometimes they include the statute in
the court order they'll talk a lot about
the facts you know I can think of a lot
of cases where I'm involved in where the
judge has said that this person
testified to this or this attorney said
this and put those facts in the court
order so over time I feel that the
courts have worked really hard to make
more detailed court orders with more
detailed reasons and rationales for why
they're making an order so those final
orders or those orders on motions have
been a lot more detailed and so I think
that perhaps the committee may want to
take a look at some of those court
orders where they can see what the judge
has done and given the rationale for why
they've made that decision and sometimes
as I've said this morning it's a matter
of somebody not not reading the rule or
not knowing how a rule applies to their
case or not understanding that where
maybe they've lost something because the
rule wasn't followed or the statute the
burden under a statute wasn't met but I
think the courts work very hard to make
very detailed orders to explain their
rationale when they're making a decision
and that is something that has changed
over time
thank you if I could just follow up do
you have any um
from your perspective can you
can you generally suggest
um that most people who go through the
family court system
um
feel that they have not been treated
well or half of the people or
25 percent or
is there any obviously I don't mean a
specific number but what we hear
is all focused in one way and I need we
need to have some sense of perspective
and I appreciate that I can honestly say
from my own perspective I have never
seen a judge be disrespectful to a
self-represented litigant matter of fact
some of us attorneys sometimes complain
that excuse some attorneys complain that
sometimes the self-represented litigant
is given more time to talk or more time
to testify in order to get that in there
I I'm sure you know I can tell that
there are people that feel differently
but I have not seen it I had a two-day
trial last fall with a gentleman who
represented himself for two days in
court and the court
gay he did a great job and the court
gave him all the time he needed to be
able to have his Witnesses and his
testimony
um and I didn't see any disrespect from
from the judge in that case and I have
not seen the judges yell at
self-represented litigants or or treat
them disrespectfully they may they may
try to shorten what they say sometimes
because they're either getting to a
place where something's irrelevant or
something's not applicable but I have
not personally seen that myself
representative catab
e thank you chairman Pearson I just
wanted to kind of follow up on what you
just said just to ask a further question
do you practice specifically in certain
courts or do you typically go to all of
the courts because perhaps some of the
issues that people are experiencing may
just have been at a court that you
don't typically practice that so it's
just trying to you know ascertain where
you typically practice or if you go to
all the courts thank you so mostly
because I'm in Nashville I mostly
practice in the Nashua and Merrimack
family divisions but I'm also in Dairy
Family Division Salem Concord I don't
tend to go too far north
um because it's not sustainable for
clients to hire me that far away but I
have cases in Keene so I do practice in
a number of the Family Division courts
thank you
representative McMahon
thank you Mr chairman
attorney candelaris uh you made a
comment earlier
I want to ask your guidance on this
where relative to The Rules of Evidence
rules of relevance
whereas the judges are
so-called the finder effect and I say
so-called depends on what facts are
being presented
your statement that stood out to me was
you stated they do not have consistent
application however
your opinion is they're fairly applied
so isn't that an inherent contradiction
and because of that do we need to
consider additional rules of how
evidence
and relevance of said evidence are
provided so each entity
the defendant and plaintiff
are fairly
accessible to the Court's power
thank you for your question
representative
in my opinion it would be difficult
because of the such the factual nature
of of family law cases so when I say
that the judges are are the they're the
the Trier of the fact so you know in
jury cases the juries find determine the
facts but in family law cases the judges
are the judges and they are the
determiner of the facts
um and because the cases are so factual
it would be hard in my opinion to make a
hard and fast rule to say that certain
pieces of evidence
need to travel a certain path before
they're admitted into evidence I think
it depends on the testimony and it
depends on the facts of the case so it's
not that the courts don't contemplate
how to receive evidence because they
have to evidence has to be authenticated
evidence has to be you know where does
this come from I just can't submit a
piece of evidence and say oh I want you
to look at this judge well the judge
want to know what it is where did it
come from who generated it there's lots
of questions that get that get asked by
the judge that are consistent but
whether the judge accepts a piece of
evidence or not again in my opinion I
think it's very relevant to what the
facts are of the case
um and what the court needs to consider
it's difficult
I'll follow up follow up very briefly uh
one question didn't want to follow real
quick after that do we would you
recommend
black letter law rules to be added to
ensure what you just stated takes place
I guess what I'm trying to say hopefully
not too inarticulately is that I think
it's difficult to make very definitive
rules for admitting evidence because of
how the facts that the judge has to hear
and what the judge needs to be able to
meet the burden under a certain law and
what might need to happen you know
whether the judge looks at a video or
whether the judge looks at a photograph
um it's just so factually related to
what might be in that video or on that
photograph and I think the Judge needs
to consider that depending on what
testimony or presentation was made by
the litigants so it's very difficult in
my opinion to make something very rigid
to say this is what someone absolutely
needs to do to submit a piece of
evidence you know stipulate to that okay
last last question I don't ask your
guidance on this you referred to the
commission your commissioner on the
access to Justice Commission yes and
what we've what I've heard from previous
testimony there's also a New Hampshire
Court Improvement project
are you aware of that of that and is
there a consensus that could come to
help and uh in this these type of
questions that we're dealing with from
those organizations I'm not really
familiar with that with that with that
project um representative I do know
there are lots of other entities there's
a the bar association has a committee on
the cooperation with the court that has
judges and lawyers that are also on that
committee there's lots of
um entities that I think help the court
communicate with the public and with
lawyers so I'm not aware of of the work
of that particular
um group okay thank you very much
attorney thank you Mr chairman
in listening to what numbers of people
have brought forward they focus on but
this is facts and I'm looking at rule
401 the test for Relevant evidence
granted this is you know but still
evidence is relevant if it has any
tendency to make a fact more or less
probable than it would be without the
evidence the fact is of consequence in
determining actions I can see all kinds
of facts that might want to be brought
up but don't help the case so the judge
may not accept it because it doesn't
serve the purpose of the trial would I
be roughly on track here I think you are
chairman and I also think that what
happens is those facts there's a burden
under the statutes whatever statute
you're trying to prove so for example if
you're trying to relocate with your
child to another state there you know
RSA
461-a you know colon 11 and 12 deal with
those kind of relocations and so some
facts help you meet the burden under the
law and some facts don't so I I would
agree with your statement
I do have one um it looks like final
question for you uh and that is could
would you review how disciplinary cases
of attorneys are done uh certainly I do
not mean specific names or specific
instances but should a hypothetical come
your way what is the process
um thank you for that question I will
admit that I I I'm going to knock on
some wood that I've not had to
experience that process myself but New
Hampshire has an attorney discipline
office and uh in a website and I know
that you can get the process or you can
go through the process if you go to that
website chairman and be able to see
exactly what needs to be done and I I'm
not
um without referencing materials on that
website
um I'm not totally Familiar of the
deadlines that need to happen but I know
that members of the public can file or
attorneys or judges can file a complaint
when attorney has when an attorney has
violated a rule and then that process
starts but that website would be very
helpful and that website would tell us
what percentage of those who would
eventually pass judgment are themselves
fellow members of the bar association as
opposed to people who are independent of
that I'm not sure if you can see the the
percentages but you can see all the
disciplinary decisions made on that
website what I'm striving for is not
specifically a decision against attorney
so and so but if there were 10 members
of the group that makes the
determination and meets out a punishment
of some degree
two lawyers and eight members of the
public versus eight lawyers and two
members of the public begs questions and
that's would that
website tell us
I'm not sure chairman but you could call
the attorney discipline office and I
know they're very helpful and be able to
point you in the right direction or
answer your questions about that
thank you representative Macbeth
thank you
I just wanted to follow up are you aware
um in malpractice our family law
attorneys are they likely to have an
increased malpractice rates are they of
do they practice in an area that
frequently litigants or unhappy thank
you for that question so I only know
from from my own malpractice carrier and
the you know legal education classes I
take from them that it seems like family
law is
one of the top if not the top areas of
of
malpractice you know along with real
estate
um I believe those are the top two areas
but I'm not positive that I only know
that from my my own uh malpractice Gary
representative ball
thank you chairman Pearson
um in your opinion or in your experience
I'm just wondering have you witnessed or
do you believe it's possible that there
could be a bias just when the parents
walk into the courtroom is already in a
bias
you know I think that there are lots of
studies about inherent bias um for
judges litigants attorneys I don't know
if the courts or the legal system has
done any work about those kind of
inherent biases
um but I don't outwardly see a bias on
just how people walking into the
courtroom are walking into the courtroom
but I know those certain biases do exist
follow-up please follow up
um in going with that I'm just going to
ask this question and I do not want to
diminish domestic violence or anything
but just because people have come to
testify and because of constituents who
have reached down to me
um
in your opinion do you see a way where
the family court can actually be
weaponized against one parent
you know it's a tough question because I
think sometimes people file
um cases they file motions they file
things because sometimes people believe
that's what they need to do I've seen it
work the other way I've been involved in
a case where a self-represented parent
has filed over you know 200 motions and
you know requests and things like that
so I think it works both ways but I
think
um you know perhaps that's how somebody
might feel but I think it's up to the
court to try to deal with you know
people filing you know duplicative
leadings or multiple pleadings
um but sure I think that sometimes the
court has to receive in motions from
attorneys and litigants that they need
to deal with and there are lots of cases
where there are multiple things filed
and cases go on for a very long time yes
one last follow-up follow-ups and um do
you feel that if or
in your professional opinion if there
was a presumption going into court of 50
50 parenting do you feel that that might
lessen the animosity of one parent
against another to try and get full
custody or just to use as I said to
weaponize the court to hurt the other
one form that I think that the committee
might want to take a look at is on the
parenting plan
um from the Family Division the very
first page of the parenting plan
um outlines what the understanding um
from the legislature in the courts about
parenting and there's a per I won't call
it a presumption there's not a
presumption in the law in my opinion but
there is sort of a presumption that
children do best when they have frequent
and continuing contact with both parents
and I do believe the court tries to
start with that premise and then the
facts come out about why a parent might
not be able to have 50 parenting time
based on what's in the best interest of
a child that's the perspective the court
always comes from again in my opinion
they look at I tell my own clients
sometimes it's not that the court
doesn't care about them but they really
care about kids and they want to make
sure that kids are safe and so when you
look at that parenting plan you can see
those the things that the court
considers when they're making a
parenting and I I think they do start
from a place where both parents should
have parenting time with the kids what
that parenting time should be really
starts to depend on the facts and then
how somebody meets their burden under
the law thank you very much I appreciate
you taking my questions and I appreciate
your honesty thank you and thank you
attorney general Harris for coming and
we'll look forward to having uh
photocopies of your presentation we'll
do that thank you all so much taking the
time to uh hear my testimony today
and next we recognize the New Hampshire
legal assistance
folks or folk or person
not just we hope you are just but you're
not just just I do my best okay
foreign
thank you thank you very much
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you so much for
inviting me to speak with you all today
my name is Aaron Jacina and I direct the
domestic violence advocacy project at
New Hampshire legal assistance are you a
lawyer I am not a lawyer I am a
paralegal and I'm happy to say that
under rule 35 which is a new Supreme
Court rule I am now able to practice
under a pilot project
in Manchester Berlin and Franklin
in domestic violence and family law
cases and I have participated and
conducted four hearings myself so far
since January 1. do you practice uh
solely
I under the rule rule 35 I am required
to be supervised by attorneys and I am
supervised by attorneys in my Law Firm
there are a number of requirements that
go along with this new rule and the law
that was passed by the legislature so I
want to first thank all of you has
increased access for our clients and New
Hampshire residents to access justice so
thank you for that and happy to answer
any questions about the paraprofessional
pilot project at any point if anyone has
any questions my aunt was a pilot
project Para
a nurse practitioner 50 years ago so I
understand the
the concept yeah thank you great thank
you uh Sue New Hampshire legal
assistance is a Statewide non-profit Law
Firm our attorneys and paralegals
represent low-income and aging clients
in civil cases involving urgent and
basic needs including safety from
domestic violence and stalking
our domestic violence advocacy project
or dbap represents low-income victims
and survivors of domestic violence
sexual assault and stalking in their
highly valid protective order cases and
in their family court cases so that's
the divorce parenting and when I refer
to highly valid cases that means there's
a high likelihood that the victim will
be killed or seriously injured by their
intimate partner and just for some
context in 2022 nhla represented nearly
200 clients in Family Division cases
Statewide so again we are a Statewide
non-profit Law Firm so that gives us a
unique perspective
uh so I thought it would be a good idea
to
um and hopefully I didn't miss the Mark
here to go through the start of the
Inception of the Family Division and
then to talk a little bit about the
goals of the Family Division when it was
first created back in 2004 really are
those goals being met in today's world
in today's Family Division World and
then what might we do going forward how
can we make things better I think that's
what the goal of this committee is it's
the goal of stakeholders I know the
public is invested so what can we do to
improve the services that are being
provided to litigants and those
accessing the Family Division through
the Circuit Court
so as you can see I put the statute in
uh from 2004 that created the Family
Division within the judicial branch and
then I broke it down really into four
different goals and I'll start with Goal
one the first goal of the Family
Division was really to
um
create the respectful treatment of all
citizens by justices marital Masters and
other family division staff and I know
you have all heard in this committee and
also in the children and family law
committee
from many public coming forward where
they are saying that's simply not the
case and I do want to respect and honor
their experiences
and those are individual experiences and
I definitely hear what litigants are
saying that they may not have received
the respectful treatment that they
should be receiving under the statute so
what are the remedies to that so if
somebody is not getting this respectful
treatment by the justices what can that
person do they can make a complaint to
the judicial conduct committee they can
complete a circuit court judicial
evaluation on the Court's website if you
go to the judicial court website
um it's not all of the justices you can
go to the particular Division and it
will list I don't know maybe four or
five judges that are up for evaluation I
think they're on a rotating schedule and
anyone can go and complete an evaluation
so that is certainly an option for
people complete an evaluation if that
judge is listed what if that judge was
evaluated last year and you're now
having a bad experience how long do you
have to wait before that person is going
to rotate up again I don't know exactly
what the rotation is Mr chairman but in
that case I would certainly reach out to
the judicial conduct committee so there
are multiple options so not only
evaluation but the judicial conduct
Committee of course there's the
Appellate process if you're having a
specific issue with your case
uh goal number two is the prompt and
fair resolution of family issues and uh
the second part of that goal is that
there are specially selected and trained
uh justices and marital Masters so is
this happening and if not why not so
um you heard attorney Chandelier's talk
about the judge shortage that is
certainly true we've talked about the
backed up dockets and I wanted to give
some context about the backed up dockets
there are cases that require certain
statutory guidelines where cases have to
be heard within a period of time so
domestic violence cases stalking cases
have to be heard within 30 days the
defendant is able to expedite those
cases the case has to be heard within
five days if somebody files an ex parte
motion within their parenting or divorce
case those cases have to be heard within
30 days so there are emergency type
cases
that are happening that need to that
need to be heard within that time frame
so it bumps the regularly scheduled
cases let's say
so in addition to that issue covid
was a huge issue the courts essentially
with the exception of non-emer uh
non-emer with the exception of emergency
type cases the courts essentially had to
shut down when covet happened much like
the rest of the state
um so you had all of those cases that
were pending pre-covered all those cases
that had hearing scheduled trials
scheduled and those had to be put on
hold unless it was an emergency so then
when but life doesn't stop life didn't
stop with covid and people were still
having issues people still wanted to get
divorced people still wanted to be
separated from their partner and needed
parenting plans
so filings were still happening they
just weren't necessarily getting
scheduled for hearings
so you had all of the cases pre-covered
that needed to be rescheduled and then
you had all the cases that were being
filed or people wanted to file during
covid so it just really overloaded the
docket and they're working really hard
to try to figure that out and prioritize
but yes it's not always leading to The
Prompt resolution of these matters
um we've talked about not there not
being enough judges
um and then in terms of the training uh
the judges need training absolutely
training is important in all professions
training is important and it's important
to be updated on
um you know what are the current best
policies and practices but the problem
when you take the judges Off the Bench
to do the training it creates more
delays because they're not hearing cases
so that's certainly something to
consider that's what the Chief Justice
told me when I gave him several things A
continuing education could be added to
all the justices in the state absolutely
and he said thank you for the seven
judges you're getting us in the budget I
said we'll see but we need we'll
probably need even more if we have more
continuing ed yes yeah
yeah
um so then you know it talks about the
Statue talks about specially selected
and trained so what does that mean so
the circuit court is made up of three
divisions it's made up of the Family
Division it's made up of the probate
Division and it's made up of the
district Division and this was really it
was created with thought and it was
meant to create an ease within the
circuit court so that a judge in
District Court could hear a Family
Division case or a probate judge could
hear district court case
um so that they could seamlessly move
between these different case types but
then you have to think does that make
sense
um
does it make sense for a judge who you
know primarily listens to misdemeanor
drug charge
cases on a daily basis to then try to
figure out the complex nature of the
best interest standard in a family court
case does that make sense it may have
made sense back in 2004 but does it make
sense today or does it make more sense
you know to continue this circuit court
but have Specialties within the Circuit
Court like what it was intended to be
probably which is a judge would hear a
specific case type it would be very
knowledgeable and have expertise in that
particular
area
so then goal number three was the use of
alternative dispute resolution to reduce
the adversarial nature of proceedings
involving families
um so I broke this down into the pros
and cons
um and and is this happening
I would say alternative dispute
resolution is happening and when I say
alternative dispute resolution I'm
referring to what we commonly talk about
is mediation is mediation happening yes
in my opinion is it heavy-handed yes why
is it heavy-handed because it's an easy
way for the docket to be cleared up
it's if cases can be resolved through
mediation
that's great you have a certified family
mediator or maybe you're using a private
mediator and you can meet and amicably
and safely meet both parties to come
together and come to a good resolution
of the case and what does that mean that
means that that's one less case on the
court stock it one less case taking up
time so yes there is in my opinion
a real push for
um for cases to go through mediation
I'm coming at it from a domestic
violence perspective and mediation in
domestic violence cases is not generally
safe there's the actual physical safety
involved with media mediating cases but
then there's that underlying coercive
control if you have one party who is an
abuser can are they really needing in
good faith to resolve the case or are
they really meeting because it's a
further way to abuse their partner
through the court system
um so that's a consideration our case is
inappropriately going to mediation
should cases be going to mediation and
if so which ones you know because
mediation has a lot of benefits in
addition to you know freeing up the
docket a little bit
but it really also embodies the mission
of the family court system which is to
reduce conflict between the parties and
reduce the tension and to honor and
acknowledge that this is a difficult
time for parties going through this I'm
sure when parties got together they
weren't initially thinking I'm going to
get divorced or we're going to have kids
together and then we're going to have to
figure out who has parenting time and
when and how are exchange is going to
happen so just honoring the experience
that litigants are going through so if
parties are able to safely and amicably
reach resolution through mediation
that's great but that's not all cases
and that's certainly not most domestic
violence cases
um
and then particularly in domestic
violence cases if you have cases that
are resolved through mediation but there
was that coercive control component
involved then that means that agreement
that final agreement isn't going to hold
up it might hold up for 30 days it might
hold up for six months but inevitably if
the
um
if the parent who was abused
you know didn't made that agreement
because they felt that they didn't have
another option then down the line it's
going to fall apart it's not going to
work it's going to be the holidays it's
going to be what was agreed to in terms
of the parenting schedule
um so what does that mean that means
then the case is going to be litigated
but it's going to go back as a
modification case and that will that
increases the court stock it
and then goal number four
the assignment of all family matters of
a single family to one Family Division
Justice or marital master
so I already spoke to this a little bit
but is this happening no it's not really
happening and this isn't me faulting the
court in any way this is recognizing
that there are issues that don't allow
for this to happen one is that contested
cases go on for years at times yeah you
know we used to in our experience
contested divorce parenting cases could
take one or two years to resolve that's
what we would tell our clients but since
covid we're looking at potentially three
four years to resolve
um and in that three to four years are
you going to have the same judge hearing
the case probably not
um you might for a little while but then
judges are frequently rotated
um among the family courts among the
family divisions so you might have a
different judge
um in year two and then you're finding
yourselves retelling
the facts of the case
um you know the judge has the file and
we'll read the file but they haven't
been invested in the case for the last
year so now you have to take the time
to really relitigate what you've gone
through for the past year because you
really want the judge to understand
what's been happening
um
so
this is this is hard it was in the
statute it's not happening and there are
a lot of reasons why it's not happening
but I think as you consider what
recommendations you might make I think
it is consistency is key
and I have spoken about consistency in
the family court system uh
in in different forums but consistency
is key across the state it helps
litigants understand and have an idea of
what to expect if you have the same
judge hearing your case if you have the
same judge that's hearing the domestic
violence case but then also here's the
parenting case they already know the
parties they know what's happening they
know the kiddos they understand the
Dynamics of this particular case but
let's say that judge gets moved they
were in Manchester and then they get
moved to Claremont and then you have a
judge that's coming from Portsmouth it's
a it sets up a whole different Dynamic
and what if that judge doesn't
um
you know
used as a different
process in terms of how they want
evidence submitted or how they want the
form submitted so consistency is key it
helps practitioners helps lawyers figure
out what is wanted when they're trying a
case but it also helps litigants to
understand what's expected of me so I
would really urge you to look at this
goal and say is that something that's
feasible is it possible to have
um you know more consistency in in
judges sitting on particular cases
so then I want to talk a little bit
about the barriers reaching some of
these goals and I know I've touched on
some of them already but I I think
generally there's a lack of
understanding of the family court system
um
it's not anyone's fault a lot of times
people don't have
um and they don't know what to expect
because they've never gone through the
process if you haven't filed for divorce
or you haven't filed a domestic violence
petition you don't know what you're
going to get when you walk through the
door particularly if you're
self-represented and I think a lot of
people their experience is based on what
they see on TV and it's not that
experience would you say that the TV
show Nightcore is not representative of
Night Court in this state you know great
show great show but yes you admitted to
watch it thank you gotcha are we talking
the spin-off are we talking the original
yes we are the original
okay yes excellent show but not the same
not at all there's no jury
um you know it's just a very different
process uh so I think lack of
understanding of the family court system
is one barrier disparity in income and
resources between the parties
um one party might have the resources to
hire an attorney the other party may not
and we represent clients free of charge
but we are us we don't have the
resources to serve everyone that comes
through our door I wish that we did but
we are turning many many people away
and oftentimes the cases that we are
getting
are the cases are either so complex that
they're not appropriate maybe for a
volunteer attorney so if we're not
taking the case then no one is taking
the case and the person is going uh to
court unrepresented and self-represented
the party's ability to hire a gal
there's no longer a court fund that pays
for Guardians ad litem so what does that
mean Jal still participate in cases
there's still
um ordered to uh for a gal to be
appointed in a case but those are only
cases where one of the parties or both
of the parties have the resources to pay
for a gal so what kind what does that
set up in terms of a system
um particularly in domestic violence
case again you've got the power and
control Dynamic what happens if Dad has
all of the money and Mom has stayed home
and dad has been abusive dad can hire
the gal and Dad recommends the gal and
that's the gal that gets appointed to
the case well how does that from the
perspective of mom
um and the vulnerable parent is Mom
going to feel comfortable in that case
talking to the gal knowing that her
abusive spouse is paying for the gal it
just sets up a bad system or lack of
Affair system
um that then there is an intersect
between uh dcyf and the court system
uh let's say
um there's a report made to dcyf that
abuse is occurring in the home either to
one of the parents or to the kiddos or
to both a report is made and dcyf
um advises the parents the vulnerable
parent to go file parenting petition or
go get a domestic violence order
um that may be at some point the right
answer but in that moment it may not be
the safest answer for that person so
let's say the parent does that follows
the advice of dcyf and they do that but
then the court says well what's dcyf
doing is dcyf involved well no dcyf is
closed the case because Mom is or the
vulnerable parent is going to take steps
to protect the child so dcyf says okay
closing the case mom has made an effort
to protect the child family court will
take it from here well Family Court
looks at it and says dcyf isn't involved
so dcyf isn't involved so is there an
issue here dcyf closed the case saying
it's unfounded so it's this cycle of
you know there is a concern but both
sides are really
um
they're hoping for input from the other
side and it's just not happening yes
yes chair recognizes the vice chair with
a question I don't want to betraying it
no it's okay
to me to end up with
dcyf having justification to say
unfounded what dcyf
could say is
um
founded with one of the
principles taking action
how can they justify saying unfounded
and I don't work for dcyf and I'm only
speaking on what I have seen in the
cases that we have handled uh and what
people have reported to me and and I
know a lot goes into
what Rises to the level of a finding
um but it
it has seemed that what does happen is
that perhaps it could rise to a level of
of a finding but what they have seen is
that Mom or the victim parent vulnerable
parent is taking steps to protect the
child and that satisfies some of the
requirements and so they they
in some cases I'm sure they do make a
finding but oftentimes it's unfounded
and then they're left to go to the
family court without a finding from dcyf
based on the abuse that they've alleged
Mr I wonder if I could ask you to
consider raising this question with the
appropriate representative from dcyf
about
exactly how they handle the situation
when they see that there is a problem
and also see that
um
steps are being taken by one of the
principals
because on on the trust but verify
approach that um
many of us feel comfortable with I
completely accept everything you say
and yet I cannot
imagine
I cannot be comfortable with that in
fact
representing the East with which dcif
could pass off the case
again I'm not suggesting that there is
necessarily an ease and there is a
thought process but a lot of it is on
the onus of the parent to protect the
child and to take the steps maybe I can
suggest that all my friends
from your group and dcuif in the courts
have a wonderful time
in mediation
finding this beautiful wonderful
protocol protocol that works so
wonderfully for the children and
everybody else involved because you're I
think pretty much good people trying to
do good things and sometimes the system
needs to be looked at and said how come
good people trying to do good things
isn't always working and I'm wondering
if that conversation could be had yes
and and I also want to assure everyone
that you know
I want you all to have a
clear picture from our perspective of
what our experience has been I don't
think you're able to make the
recommendations that you need to make if
we're not all very upfront with what is
happening within the system and how we
can fix it and they're just lying hey
excuse hey quiet audience will be quiet
or we'll leave
and we are 100 having these cover
s covering those difficult conversations
so this working together is an ongoing
process so we're going to hear very very
few cases going forward because of
whoops how did we
come up with something that just isn't
working it's not a perfect system no
it's not but it can be better 100 could
be better on all forums you know this
isn't just the court or dcyf or you know
one particular agency or group this is
we all need to work collectively and if
I'm able to get through the rest of my
presentation I will absolutely let you
know the good work that all of these
groups are you will and could we have a
report back in September as to how you
you don't have to go into details unless
we have to make some recommendations or
legislation out of it but just a little
note signed by everybody that hey we met
over hot dogs over the summer and we had
a wonderful time and tossed the Frisbee
and ate corn on the cob and worked out
some of these things just keep us in the
loop would you you may continue thank
you
experiences you've heard a lot of them
are these systemic issues that we're
talking about on a Statewide level are
these individual cases individual issues
and are we talking about really read
dismantling or restructuring an entire
system based on any particular
individual I think there's a lack of
understanding of domestic violence and
the effects of trauma and how victims
present when they have either been
abused domestically domestic abuse by
their partner or sexual abuse or
stalking
gender-based biases within the system
inappropriate access to language access
services and lack of necessary resources
you know we're tying our judges hands
that we have situations where kiddos the
safest option for them if a parent is to
have is to have parenting time with that
kiddo is supervised visitation
we're tying our judges hands because we
have one safe supervised visitation
center left in this state and their
funding I believe ends in December of
this year one safe supervised visitation
center left that uses a metal detector
that follows best practices
so and and that Center is in Stratford
County
but they accept uh cases from all over
the state not just Stratford County but
who who from the North country is going
to drive to Stratford County to be able
to use supervised visitation and so what
does that mean for our judges you know
they they very much want to I mean you
can read in the statute
um what the goal of RSA 461a is to
support frequent and continuing contact
when it's safe to do so and sometimes
that's within the supervised visitation
center but what if we don't have
supervised visitation centers anymore
what is the judge going to do the judge
is going to balance no parenting time
for this person or unsupervised
parenting time for this person and those
neither of those are good options so we
really do need to think about what
resources are available
batterers Intervention Program batteries
intervention Intervention Program
so then I want to talk a little bit
about the myths that
um
come up frequently in
um children family law committee I
believe they've been raised in this
committee as well
um you know we talk about a lot with 50
50 shared parenting
um and that parental rights and
responsibilities the default
automatically goes to Mom
that's that's not true
um in fact mothers are more likely to
lose custody of their children when
allegations of abuse are made against
the father could we have some
documentation
study for you you are very quick we have
this study thank you so I I do want to
acknowledge that
um that moms in family court it's not
automatic it's not the default and
oftentimes when they do raise
allegations of abuse whether it's
physical abuse or sexual abuse that they
are more likely to lose custody of their
kids even if there have been findings of
abuse even if it has been proven that
there are allegations
um are true against the father
committing committing abuse that they
are still likely to lose custody
uh and then gender bias against women
does exist within the system you have
I mentioned that um
victims are often experiencing uh
effects of the trauma and that spills
over into the family court case
um they are in court at a table next to
their abuser uh they are
re-triggered they're triggered uh they
are often emotional uh they are unable
to present their case particularly if
they're self-represented
um because that's what trauma does and
and I when I talk about biases I think
um the opposite is true if somebody is
alleging abuse and
um judge sees that person and they have
an idea in their head of how is a victim
supposed to behave how is a victim
supposed to testify oh they're supposed
to be crying oh they're supposed to be
hysterical well this person isn't doing
any of those things so did it happen
those kinds of biases we are constantly
training the judges on that we have to
let go of these biases but for the
parent or the mom that is presenting in
a particular way that is presenting as a
typical Vic dumb uh that they are
hysterical and emotional and unable to
present their case and that hurts them
they because the abuser oftentimes is
put together is able to articulate uh
and that's part of the continued abuse
and
um
it does not bode well all the time for
moms in those cases and that's where the
statistic comes in because they can't
they can't present well
I'm going to ask representative ball for
her question because I think we're
trying to as presented thank you
thank you chairman
[Music]
but wouldn't all of this still be true
for the father who's being accused
um
unjustly that he might also present as a
little bit upset and maybe even
aggressive in the courtroom because he's
afraid of losing his children
if the father has been accused all right
thank you for the question I'm saying
even if the father has not been accused
even if he believes it's a false
allegation for it's going two ways I'm
saying it's a very emotional time in the
courtroom and shouldn't both parents be
given some degree of latitude of
understanding that
um this is emotional the children are
involved maybe one or both didn't ever
even expect to be in the courtroom for a
divorce
um so I'm I'm kind of a little concerned
when
um we keep referring to females as the
only victims in the courtroom
that's just my opinion and I don't want
to be little domestic violence but I've
also heard and I just correct me if I'm
wrong but wouldn't also emotional abuse
and verbal abuse be considered not just
sexual and not just physical abuse isn't
that all abuse
thank you for the question and for
making that distinction I would 100
agree with you that emotional abuse
psychological abuse Financial abuse all
of that is abuse unfortunately that is
not the definition of abuse under New
Hampshire state law so it does not
include those factors do you have the
RSA on abuse statute I I don't have it
with me but I can tell you that it's
sexual assault physical assault
harassment interference with freedom
which would be stalking destruction of
property and abuse of pets I believe
I'm sorry oh and criminal threatening
thank you I left that one out
thank you very much for that
clarification I very much appreciate it
thank you
so yes I do want to acknowledge
um also to your point representative
ball that
um there are K I'm here because I work
exclusively with domestic violence
victims primarily who are women
um statistically uh women are making
more reports of domestic violence and
statistically you know I think it's one
in I I don't actually want to quote the
exact number I can certainly get that
for you that is not to say that there
are not male victims of domestic
violence and we do represent male
victims of domestic violence but for the
cases where we are providing
representation our clients are primarily
female
um but there are cases that do not
involve domestic violence at all uh in
Family Court uh and certainly even in
those cases where there is no domestic
violence yes emotions are going to run
very high and
um you know it is and um it is a
difficult process and yes everybody
should be given in some Grace in the
family court system because and there is
a recognition of that in the statute I
think that there should be recognition
that this is a difficult and a difficult
process and the goal is to make it so
it's not adversarial unfortunately that
is not always how things shake out
um
so
and again I'm talking about protective
mothers and the experience because again
that's what you'll see in the report
that I provided but also
um this is our primary client population
that protective moms are often seen as
hyper Vigilant and overly protective
um strides that they take to protect
their children when a system fails them
raises allegations of Parental
alienation syndrome which is not in fact
A syndrome it is oftentimes used as a
tactic by abusive fathers to further
abuse within the family court system
because they're no longer able to do
that within the confines of their home
yes representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman
specific to that subject you just
brought up and what we had testimony
from
the attorney chandeliers
judged system would decide The Rules of
Evidence or relevance and as stated that
parental alienation syndrome is not a
recognized syndrome and I'm just a defer
a moment is that by what higher
authority would it be a recognized
syndrome if it was in the DSM which is
lists all of the different syndromes and
mental health as of which Edition did it
come in
it's not in there it's not it's not okay
okay then then the follow-up one uh
follow up thank you Mr chairman then on
that subject matter
under the current
environment of the court system would
not the J with
other judges not
eliminating that uh under relevance and
evidence because it's not a recognized
syndrome
uh thank you for the question uh it is
my experience that that
has been raised in family court and
whether or not somebody calls it
parental alienation syndrome or calls it
parental alienation that those facts are
in fact considered in some decisions
then one final clarification then
because yes this is thank you Mr
chairman this is going on to the when we
have a discussion as a committee on what
rules to recommend
is this then an opinion on a statement
made in this case by one party not
necessarily saying male or female but
just one party
that then it is
The Scholar letter of Pas is put on the
interpretation of that statement versus
what the facts are
thank you for the question
um I think that can absolutely play out
that way I think that one parent for
example could be make could be talking
to the pediatrician could be talking to
dcyf they're doing that because they're
scared that something is going on with
the child because the child has either
told them or the child is exhibiting
symptoms of abuse or neglect and so
they're taking these steps to protect
the child but to
the other side the person who is being
accused of doing those things to the
child can raise these well she just
doesn't want I will the other parent who
is doing these things is saying these
things because they don't want me to
have time with the kid I'm a great
parent but they don't want me to have
time with the kids because they're upset
with me about X Y and Z and so the court
considers those things
um and considers oh maybe this parent is
doing those things because
they don't want the other parent to have
any time with the kids and how would the
court determine that in a criminal court
you've got all your investigators and
everything what do you have in Family
Court
that's an excellent question thank you
for that uh chairman Pearson oftentimes
in Family Court the only evidence that
you have is the party's testimony and
that is evidence I think oftentimes
we're very much looking for where's the
document where's the police report
where's the medical record which is a
whole other issue but where are those
things and oftentimes there are not
there those things aren't there you just
have the testimony of uh the parties
maybe some witnesses and that's it and
the judge needs to make a determination
based on who they found was more
credible and again that goes into my
discussion on presentation from either
parent
this can get a little dicey I think you
are correct
and we need to improve this so we need
to think about how to do this
not right now but we do
yes yes uh representative Macbeth making
a great effort in spite of
thank you thank you so I just wanted to
point out that
um there are statutes
um and 461 a
six that was mentioned by attorney
shenzelis earlier today it's
specifically has like 11
um criteria that the courts to look at
that the legislature has come up with
and at least two of them if not three
have to do with which parent will
promote the relationship with the other
parent despite harm to them so this
stuff about um alienation or parents
that are making allegations it is
addressed in the statute not only in
those three separate sections
um in the under the parental
responsibility but I can't speak to that
right now but I will provide that to the
committee I think that's what you're
looking for is what standard like of
best interest
so the testimony on Parental alienation
while she's correct is not a syndrome
listed in the DSM number four or any but
it is the step the legislature has
provided stats you know um criteria for
the court to look at in that area
um
so
so I know I've I've put a lot out there
and given you
um a lot of information
um so you know we talked about in 2004
what did what was the intent of the
legislature what was what was in the
Statue what were the goals of the Family
Division at that time
kind of what is happening currently from
our experience in our Statewide practice
but I know you want some ideas about
what do we do from here so I was hoping
to and I want to keep it positive and I
want to tell you about all the good work
that is happening because there is a lot
of good work that is happening because
people are recognizing that these things
are happening within the family court
system and what can we do to correct it
obvious answers are more funding and
more people to do the work
um you know this is the system that we
have and you know we're not looking to
dismantle an entire system or start from
scratch
um so what what can we do with this
system how can we enact change within
the current system that we have so there
are access to Legal remedies
um
people who go through the court process
and are not happy with the orders there
are multiple stages along the way where
somebody can
try and get a change to their order so
let's say somebody gets an order either
a temporary order or in their divorce
case or a final order in their parenting
case and they don't agree with it they
think the judge just completely got it
wrong either they made an error based on
the law or they didn't understand
particular facts they can file a motion
for reconsideration they have 10 days to
file a motion for reconsideration
from there if it's a final order they
can file a New Hampshire Supreme Court
appeal they can access the judicial
conduct committee and evaluations that
are online I think
rightfully so that there were some
recent issues within the family court
system and I know you have heard from
the public on these issues and those
issues were corrected those judges are
not sitting on the bench anymore so
there was a response it may not have
fixed the entire problem but it wasn't
ignored there was a response and respect
the work that's being done
um
I think everybody is genuinely well
intended and we are not uh perfect
people all the time it's an imperfect
system and we're humans and we make
mistakes but we are
um working hard to address those things
uh in 2021 at the end of 2021 I'm sure
you're all familiar with the situation
where a woman was denied a final
protective order out of Hampton Family
Division and
um several weeks later her ex-partner
shot her in as she was leaving her work
in Salem Massachusetts and that was a
tragedy and it's unfortunate that a
tragedy really
pushed us to enact all of this change
but as a result of that there was an
internal review within the Family
Division there was the New Hampshire
Supreme Court set up a task force on
domestic violence cases in the New
Hampshire judicial system I sat in on
that task force as a result of that task
force we produced I think it was a
61-page report with multiple
recommendations I am happy to say that
that is not a report that is sitting on
a shelf that we are enacting those we
are making those changes we are looking
at those recommendations the governor
reinstated as a result of the task force
the governor's Commission on domestic
violence they are working diligently to
make changes
there was a call for increased resources
for civil legal aid we started a
Manchester Domestic Violence Clinic as a
response we are on site every Thursday
at the Manchester Family Division
on-site representing victims in their
domestic violence cases as they come to
court so that is on demand on-site
Services every Thursday and we started
that back in October as um
as a result of the task force report
I think we need data there needs to be a
better way to track case outcomes so we
can see are these one-off cases are
these is this a systemic issue or is
this one particular case one particular
catchment area
we need to look at perhaps exploring the
implementation of civil domestic
violence courts within the Family
Division and I have a handout for you
about what civil domestic violence
courts look like so that you know and
this this is in line with one judge
hearing
the same similar types of cases so the
same judge here's the domestic violence
case the same judge here's the parenting
case we need to have additional judge
training on domestic violence and the
aces which is adverse childhood effects
um and more consistency across the state
and how courts and judges are applying
court rules and protocols and
um one of those programs which is
produced by the batter of women's
Justice project is called the safer
program and it's it enables
professionals and judges and courts to
look at these cases in a similar way and
to ask similar questions so that there
is consistency across the state so a
case that's being heard in Keene is
being handled in a similar similar way
to a case that's being heard in ossipy
and I apologize I only have one copy of
that for the chair I wasn't able to make
multiple color copies and it requires
color
um
do we have a color printer on the fourth
floor
it is so huge but it's still black and
white okay
we do
we don't
okay I'm sorry we're just you know
that's fine and I do just want to
address one additional and then I'm
happy to take any questions
um a question that came up with attorney
Shannon Alaris is that can I think it
was I don't know if it was specific to
the family court system or just 50 50
shared parental responsibilities could
that be used to weaponize
um the system and it is my opinion based
on uh the work that we do with domestic
violence victims that yes uh the process
can be weaponized the family court
system can be weaponized shared parental
responsibility or 50 50 can be
weaponized because oftentimes in
domestic violence relationships
one the most dangerous time to leave is
the most dangerous time for a victim is
when they are making efforts to leave
that relationship and so that includes
filing for a divorce or seeking a
protective order so
if the jumping off point is 50 50. and
I've said this in prior testimony if the
jumping off point is 50 50. that is
something that will be used by abusers
to keep that victim in the home because
if that victim knows that they have been
abused and that their kiddos have been
abused and that's there's potential for
that child to be abused outside of their
care if they know that the court is
likely to Grant you the abuser 50
percent of the parenting time what what
incentive does that victim have to leave
in that case because they won't because
at least a hundred percent of the time
if both parents are in the home with the
kiddos they can see what's going on they
can intervene they can protect that
child but if it's 50 50 and they know
that and the abuser says if you leave me
you know what's going to happen I'm
going to have Johnny I'm going to have
Susan 50 of the time and there's nothing
that you can do about it that is
terrifying absolutely terrifying because
they will want to and then they will
want to stay and they will in that cycle
of abuse will continue
and parents will be hurt and kids will
be hurt so a hundred percent in my
opinion based on the work that we have
done on a daily basis across the state
on behalf of victims yes the family
court system can be weaponized yes 50 50
custody can be weaponized thank you
thank you for your testimony and I have
not heard such beautiful round O vowels
since my last trip to Wisconsin and
Minnesota
are you a native New Englander I am yes
and yet your o vowels are so wonderful
sorry that that was just an aside uh any
uh questions
any questions none thank you so much I
will just hand it just to the end of the
row yeah that's good
an extra he says
okay that goes to
well we're now starting to look at pink
cards left over from last week
and the chair recognizes Melinda
Nicolosi
was was are you uh two people one
selection kind of says because I think I
remember Renee Martinez
are you testifying together
I can't hear you
I it still needs to be on
we I'm going to tell story before
you know what I still cannot hear you
I'm going to testify before her because
my case leads into her case okay then go
okay
and you are I'm Renee Martinez
okay my sister Melinda nicolosia is in a
litigation in Derry family court in New
Hampshire
um
okay so start the clock
and this is one case right
it's two seconds it's two separate cases
two separate cases I have a stocking
case
that led to my what happened in my
sister's case
okay let's hear your case okay so
um
thank you
on May 13th 2022 I obtained a no
stalking order against the ex-boyfriend
of my sister who currently this
ex-boyfriend has custody of her son
on May 16 2022 the ex the ex's lawyer
sent my sister an email telling her that
because of my order my protective order
against his client his client will be
suspending her parenting time effective
immediately and reminded her after that
that she could not file a contempt
against his client for interfering with
her parenting time because she's
defaulted out of the case and the court
advised her
at this point that she cannot file
motions
um
and has refused all of her emotions that
she's attempted to file including
contempt motions
on June 2nd two weeks after they put in
their motion to suspend her parenting
the judge granted their prayer to in
quote suspend mother's parenting time
and Skype calls until the sister's
protective order is dismissed
this was he the judge did not modify the
prayer he just wrote granted underneath
that prayer
um at this point he was predicting that
my case was going to be dismissed or he
knew that my case was going to be
transferred down to him
um
okay I believe there's been extreme bias
in my sister's case and when there was a
warrant issued from my sister's arrest
because she was protecting her immune
compromised son
um from what his former doctors advised
her could seriously harm or even kill
her son
um she had a warrant they obtained a
warrant based on a lie that um they
filed with the police
um she can explain more about that
and my stocking case
my stocking case was petitioned in
Manchester
um I didn't tell my sister I didn't tell
either of my sisters that I was
um
filing the petition because they were
afraid they were afraid that what ended
up happening happened and even then some
um once I obtained the petition from
Manchester when they granted me the
stocking order that's when I told them I
had tried many things I my sister had
called her emailed or texted her ex
warning him that if he didn't stop
harassing me or stalking me he stalked
me four times
that she that I was going to do
something I sent him I asked her to
email him and tell him that I would do
counseling with him to find out what was
underlying why he felt uncomfortable
around me as he claimed to her and I
um
I sent a deceased a cease and desist
order for him to sign he refused I sent
him in his attorney a letter an
agreement letter refused I did many
things to try to avoid going to the
court but he kept on harassing me
um and I finally went announced
Manchester they gave it to me and his
attorney put in to Manchester Court that
if they didn't transfer this case down
to the same judge that has been
exclusively
um overseeing my sister's case that it
would take at least a three-hour trial
for Manchester to hear my case and so
they he basically scared Manchester into
sending my case down to the judge that's
overseeing my sister's case who I feel
has been very biased and has silenced me
throughout my sister's case while I'm a
key witness and had been present at
every event almost that has happened
since we lived together since my nephew
you was in the oven
um
so
okay
oh I'm sorry
Okay so
[Music]
let me just catch up here
I'm giving you a double portion of time
because there's two of you so you do
have a little bit more time but not
infinite so these pauses are counting
against your time I just need you to
move on okay okay
um basically my case was moved down to
um the to this same judge and he
um he refused me all of my Witnesses
basically
um he
put things in the orders that I after
correct making the corrections in the
um
the hearings were still reflected even
though he said he was making the
corrections they were still reflected in
the final order he dismissed my case
um and during that time he did I asked
the judge to modify the order so because
he was hurting a mother and child when
they didn't do anything wrong there was
nothing that my sister did nothing that
the child did it was basically to
protect the man from potentially
violating my order
um that her parenting was suspended and
this continued my case was continued
three times postponing continued three
times and
it went on for
about 250 days and I kept asking the
court to please modify and
um he wouldn't modify it he
um just kept continuing it as requested
by the um by the defendant or her ex
so
um I'm gonna lead you into my sister's
case because her her parenting was not
only suspended but ultimately terminated
as a result of my water protecting this
man
and I'm going to ask you
for specifics if you say the witnesses
weren't allowed to testify what
Witnesses why were they not
Ayan listed about 16 Witnesses so this
is in the documents you gave us no the
document you have is my sisters okay
I'm going to email everything supporting
everything I say because that's the only
thing that will help us as we're
considering it we're not retrying the
case yes a broad generalization is of no
use
so you have to give us specific details
if a judge said no did someone object
what was the objection what was the
judge's answer what did you do next
those are the things that will help us
okay okay so so when my case got moved
to Manchester I gave many reasons why it
shouldn't be my case was a civil case
and this judge after admitting that he
was not allowed to use any of his prior
information knowledge of me in my
sister's case he wouldn't move it back
to Manchester
um Manchester mistakenly moved my case
into the a different jurisdiction but he
he held on to my case
um and was the change of venue objected
to officially on the record many times
motions and in hearings okay again go
specific on that if you can chair
recognizes one of the clerks
thank you chairman Pearson thank you for
coming and testifying and for taking my
question which court was it moved to
Derry District Court thank you you're
welcome
when I
um
when I submitted a motion to violate the
defendant
um on August 29th we had I had submitted
three three motions one was for him to
release who we had tracking me on
Facebook
um and another one was for because I had
thought that the order said for him to
attend counseling
um one was to order the counseling and
the other one was to violate him those
three two of those were supposed to be
addressed on August 29th at our
pre-trial conference
um and The Judge first said he didn't he
wasn't aware that they were and I and I
I showed him and he said okay in the
case summary or the order
um and he he said that um
he wasn't
in that hearing he refused to address
those two contempts
um and he had already decided before
that hearing that he wasn't going to
address the motion of violate and I
asked the judge why he wouldn't be
addressing that motion to violate
because that would take care of both
cases what was happening in both cases
at the same time and resolve probably
both cases and he didn't give me a
reason
um he and he postponed all of the
Motions to the final hearing which was
delayed over 100 days after that I think
we now have 30 seconds to bring this to
a close okay
both of you I gave you 10 minutes you
have 30 seconds now to conclude your
testimony
if you are not providing us the
specifics then email us
we have your written testimony and I
will give you 30 seconds to summarize it
I guess I have just suggestions I would
like to
um ask
um I I guess when you're a defaulted
party
um how how to
um how to I guess become not defaulted
um because they're holding that
um against me and
um using that in all my emotions
everything I I submit to the court it's
um everything's always okay I'm gonna
stop you now and
I will give you the opportunity to
revise your testimony because it is not
helpful to us okay that's not an insult
against you it does not in any way
diminish what you're going through but
it's not helpful testimony because when
it says the judge has not afforded me
the right to prevent present evidence
what kind of evidence no no I'm not I'm
asking you to write this those are
specifics
ignoring All the Rules of Evidence which
rules are they
don't answer me put it in your new email
to us he has denied me the right to ask
for Discovery do you have a copy of that
motion when was it presented were you
representing yourself or did you have
legal counsel we need specifics because
right now these are generalizations that
do not help us make changes
so as I've been saying and I know some
people are tired of me saying this every
week that is the testimony that will be
helpful so I'll give you a shot at doing
it doing a do-over
through a much better prepared detailed
testimony and that will be good for us
because I think you're on to something
here okay we just need to know so I'm
going to
now and I'm going to call some other
people okay
so we'll be looking forward to it thank
you I think you got a lot of stuff
do you have an email okay thank you and
now I'm going to call from
um from from
from
Michael's Is It Michael spite or Spate
Spate
please be seated and turn on your
microphone and remember you have five
minutes yeah first I'd like to say that
uh you know all that stuff about uh
domestic violence and everything in
child alienation uh my ex-girlfriend
went to uh three different courts and
try to get restraining orders on me and
uh not in one of them stick stuck at a
Derry District Family Court
um
I haven't seen my kid in a year and I've
been paying child support and uh I'll
tell you what the judge did wrong there
is um she she put in a motion to file
for uh to have a dismissed and move to
Massachusetts in July of last year and
it was denied jurisdiction was in New
Hampshire
and then another judge came in in
November which I still haven't seen my
kid the whole time and he heard the case
on an oral motion which is against the
law because you can't hear the same
motion with the same evidence over and
over again uh New Hampshire Circuit
Family Court the division one two six
motion for reconsideration she didn't
preserve her right for appeal
and uh the second judge overheard it and
then if you want to go into appellate
court cases you got Rasta Kelly versus
kirlwin out of North Carolina same
issues same motion second judge can't
handle the same motion as a first judge
because it was already denied and then
um not only that it was an oral motion
to dismiss
and he was supposed to give me 30 days
to prepare for the motion he heard it
that day so what I'm saying is if it's
all up to discretion of the judge
everybody's screwed
do you have those specific things that
you've just mentioned I got them all on
my phone I can print you out my appeal
that's in the Supreme Court right now I
would like that much better than having
your phone
if you could print
um email it to you not only that not
only that like if uh you know like I
haven't seen my daughter in a year this
is my daughter
that's me
and I'll show you another picture of my
daughter not one allegation of abuse I
haven't seen her in a year
if that could be printed out and sent to
sent to us this would be very specific
kinds of things and there's more and
there's more she got caught lying four
times she said she lived with me five
years in Massachusetts then in Derry
I'll send you the transcript she said I
didn't have anything to do with the baby
four and a half years of a life she lied
in all transcripts her loyal I
truthfulness of a statement perjury not
only that she kidnapped my kid and took
her to Massachusetts nobody did anything
about it okay
yeah you know and talk about child
alienation I haven't seen my kid in a
year okay chair's going to ask the vice
chair she's got a question
domestic violence case is before The
Supreme Court no there is no domestic
violence case she went for three
restraining orders and they all were
denied
so if I could what is the case that's
before this jurisdiction Derry we lived
in Derry for a year I bought a house in
Derry we lived there for a year that's
the baby's home state I filed for
custody three days after she left
she and I
she got Massachusetts to intervene which
is against uh Massachusetts law and the
Department of Justice laws okay thank
you very much so Department of so
Massachusetts put in a temporary order
until they got the parent and petition
from New Hampshire I sent it to the
Department of revenue's lawyer to give
to the judge he withheld it I have that
email too I'll send I'll send you all
the evidence that would be helpful what
I'm saying is you know if uh people
can't get
it right and straighten out the system
people are going to find a new system
that works for them understood right and
that means the people above them
the people that oversee it
so right now what I'm doing is I'm
putting in a uh
I'm getting together uh
um visitation enforcement agency not
state funded not federally funded
that's going to help people get
visitation for their kids okay we're
going to bring it to a close because are
there any questions from us on
uh sorry Michael
s-p-e-i-g-hd
so yeah that'd be helpful I think we've
come to a conclusion here you yep and
we've got the specific that's fine what
are you going to do with all my
paperwork just uh read it and uh shred
it
what would you like us to do with it I
would like you to do something about the
courses
chair recognizes uh Robin is it Patel
patello okay
um sorry I should I have some good
training on
owes a minute ago so I got it now thank
you Robin yeah partello thank you chair
Robin partello I am a resident of Nashua
New Hampshire I've been in the National
Family Division for four years my case
actually just came to a conclusion but
it's not
through the appeal process so I'd prefer
not to get into specifics
um I have had interactions excuse me you
are going to have to get into some
specifics well the testimony is to be
helpful to us correct correct not of my
case specific details okay all right
we'll see how it works I have a
different
um angle to present okay so I've had
interactions with the judicial conduct
committee which I was successful the
professional conduct committee and the
gal board
um my issue to present here today is
about the process and the individual
before me actually gave me a pretty good
roadmap because what he was saying was
correct
um when you go into a courthouse you
sort of have expectations or there's
clear guidance and that's the problem
with the family court and what he's
saying is that a judge held a hearing
prematurely and I see that happen all
the time and it is scary because the
process in family court is you go in for
your first appearance then you have a
temporary hearing then you have a
scheduling hearing then you have perhaps
motion hearing then your final hearing
when you go in for the scheduling
conference hearing you are expecting to
set dates for discovery
what the court is doing is they call it
suaspante or on its own they have a
emotion hearing and I wouldn't have
believed it if I didn't read the
transcript myself but I've seen two
different courts completely strip a
parent of their parental rights in this
status conference and I listened to the
attorney object object object it was a
due process violation and the courts
still do it and that's my issue with
discretion is if I say to you
you know you have to do something in a
reasonable fashion what does reasonable
mean to you because if it has a sense of
urgency I say 24 hours it would be
helpful in those cases that you alluded
to if you could email us with specifics
when what judge because I can see
examples when uh I would have ruled that
way I can also see examples when that
was an incorrect ruling but I can't
decide about what you've said because I
don't have enough specifics so to be
helpful again if you would give us that
and you can email the committee that
would open up some possibilities for us
excellent I I have a transcript and I'll
point out to the specific paragraphs
that you guys don't have to go through a
200-page transcript thank you difficult
and my last and final point is the
process on gal PCC
issues if you have an issue with your
gal the court says go to the gal board
but what you don't know is that the gal
board will not hear a complaint about a
gal in an ongoing case my case lasted
for four years I could not file a
complaint I filed with the PCC they said
go to the JC's go to the gal board now
that I can file guess what I have a
statute of limitation issue now I can't
file so essentially the gal board is
really tying the hands of litigants to
file a legitimate complaint
and that's all I have for you today
if you could give us a one-pager about
what you just said about gal that would
be helpful too because we could look at
that specific issue of how do you
complain against the gal apparently only
when it's too late yeah and the other
issue is that you're sworn to
confidentiality on all of these
complaints that you make so in my
judicial conduct committee complaint I
was not allowed to tell a soul that I
had complained about this judge but what
she was allowed to do
was go back to that courtroom and train
a new judge to take over my case
so clearly there
I can't prove it but in the mind I would
think that there's a bias
from that judge and there's also
the issue on judges
I noticed that there's a shortage and I
have you know sent emails to some
attorneys that I've dealt with that are
just amazing and would be amazing judges
but the problem and I don't think you
would see this is
old school attorneys don't type their
own stuff they have secretaries they
sometimes struggle with attaching
something to an email if they become a
judge they're a one man or one woman
show and they don't have the capability
of drafting all of their orders so
perhaps if you look at the process it
might make sense to attract new judges
to offer a law Clerk or a secretary
somebody who could assist them because
in Massachusetts there's layers to get
through you go through a case manager
all of these layers so when you get to
the judge it's not such a heavy burden
in New Hampshire we're going straight to
a judge and saying solve all of our
problems if we're pro se and we don't
have child support can you help us
figure out how to do it it's just too
much on the judges and I think the
process can be expedited and
you know more beneficial if there were
layers to assist that judge okay thank
you thank you I hope this will be in the
written wow you're good look at that uh
we'll be in your written testimony too
because I can see a couple things right
now that'll be very helpful as we start
to consider things so thank you so much
thank you
chair recognizes from Derry New
Hampshire it looks like
TJ or TT
TJ
oh yeah there it is okay got it
and
thank you
thank you chairman and yeah we are
before you are allowed to begin we would
like your name please
Noonan with an m
spell it again
okay Mr moonan thank you okay
um
I um I have a I have a daughter she's 32
years old I've seen her total of 70
minutes in the last 25 years
I've been working
um with non-custodial parents or
dependencies I like to call them
to help them to re-establish a
relationship with their children and
I've seen a lot of good things happening
with that um
it's amazing what I've seen in my work I
don't have any uh qualifications of not
a paralegal or a lawyer or anything like
that but
what I've seen through my own education
is um
there's there are a lot of discrepancies
that don't make sense
the the courts are given Financial
incentives uh to collect child support
and the agencies are given incentives to
remove children from families
but there's no money given to visitation
enforcement like something like Mrs
state was talked about I'm working I'm
actually I'm working with the state
senator and a couple of Representatives
excuse me and a member of the executive
account
sorry um
to create a visitation enforcement agent
here in New York and I'm working with
other people in different states to do
the same thing there
um
it's just it's very confusing I I got
divorced in 1992 and I went into court
thinking I knew everything and I didn't
realize that you know
you don't get if you can afford a lawyer
you don't get one
um
and there's no jury trial I get
convicted twice for being behind on my
child support no jury trial or anything
and you know it's just you pay it or
else and I spent over a hundred thousand
dollars of Child Support without having
any contact with my daughter because of
false allegations
my ex-wife accused me of something and
she didn't have to prove it happened I
had to prove it didn't I don't
understand that at all do you have a
date when that took place in the uh we
our visit stopped in 1997 in 1998
because it would be uh very helpful just
for the audience we are not receiving
any more pink cards today we are already
gone over noon so if you want to fill
one out for next week go ahead
um it would be helpful if we could have
specific details I can give you details
it was in Massachusetts I can give you
the documentary you would need to be
written out and sent to the committee or
and so on
it was oh it was in Massachusetts I live
in uh Gary now and I work okay thank you
do you have a New Hampshire case that
you're presenting before us no I just
wanted to get the uh information out
there okay find out why if we can answer
this why is visitation not in the best
interest of the child
with both parents I wouldn't we would
not know that it sounds like the
decision was made in Massachusetts well
no it's everywhere you I mean there's no
visitation enforcement agent
okay and you had said that you have been
speaking with an executive council
member and at least okay if you if you
could type that out who who are you
talking with because maybe we want to
talk with them too um specifically
mostly uh with Senator Evart given ibar
all right and um along with Erica Leon
and uh Janet Stevens okay
how many people I've been working with
yeah good that'd be helpful okay we may
want to ask them this thank you
unfortunately Kimberly Bryce and it
wasn't available
all right she's getting better she's
healing up so thank you sir appreciate
this is what we need okay and uh
got a couple cards left from
Vivian Gerard
and has been patiently waiting out there
since the crack of dawn come on up
thank you chair and members of the
committee
um I just wanted to bring up a couple of
things that have come up this morning
with Catherine she said that
um a lot of different facts that I think
are very misleading and as you know
um chair Pearson that I've been up here
several times
and I do actually have a letter from the
judicial conduct committee it's taken
many many times many tries on my case
and some of you are new here based on my
case so I am the Silva V Silva case and
in my case I've been to several
different bad judges I've I've
unfortunately at the very beginning of
my divorce I do believe that there's a
problem with the um the good old boys
club committee uh where my opposing
councils
um
inappropriately I believe that again
specific
I have them all here got them all and
we're going to get one I'll give you the
copies of it I'm trying to start like um
scratch the surface of it because again
I had 29 hearings I had five Supreme
Court appeals my biggest problem is I
had two judges that both got disbarred
while one was a marital Master which we
no longer have it went to the um to the
court they said that they were not gonna
um first of all I was told that I
had a hobby and to go out and get a real
job that they took away child support
and alimony which they had no right
doing that is to support the children
they took away my alimony because of my
business there's been a lot of judicial
Discretions and she even said on the
bench that she should not be making this
Rule and without looking at the law that
applies to alimony but she said
regardless of the relationship it
doesn't matter if it's a business deal
you're losing it and after going to the
Supreme Court five times do we have a
place cited where somebody could go back
and hear that said yes yep actually and
you've transcribed that and referenced
it in your notes yep actually um the
other problem that I do have
um is the first comment that I had
received from the first judge that was
not on transcript but I do have
witnesses that have heard it
um the other
um comments which again
I have a Judicial conduct complaint here
that marital Master uh delpra
specifically said that he was not going
to fix the reman orders that came from
the Supreme Court
because I was a thorn in his side he
said that um he did not want to reopen
the can of worms on my case because it's
been so many years so even though they
had very explicit orders from the
Supreme Court to fix my case he said he
was not reopening that can of worms was
that conveyed to someone who works in
the Supreme Court office you know that's
a good question so it was heard by the
judicial conduct committee on record we
have no transcript no audio that has
that specific
saying but Robert middleholzer and it
also says here these comments were
confirmed by the committee upon its
review of the audio recordings of the
above herons so as I had sat before you
many times to tell you that there's been
so many processes where are not being
followed for instance like I said the
the Supreme Court gave them explicit
instructions I have the Supreme Court
ruling here that says exactly what I
what it's due to me and my children it
went down to the trial court the trial
court said nope you don't deserve it
again said on on record okay did you
then rat that Court out to the Supreme
Court I did okay I went again five times
to the Supreme Court again I got another
remand that says I gave you explicit
instructions to fix this case and you
know what the the next judge did he said
I am not reopening this can of worms
so it's been a trend where I was biased
up against at the very beginning and I
feel like the court is at playing field
where otherwise these people would be
put in jail for instance my ex
originally had given me as false 30
seconds left sorry uh false TVs fall
police report false um
court cases false gcyf reports criminal
threatening conspiracies I even had a DV
put against me which when I went into
court the judge said he's the one that
should have this he's preventing your
business he's stopping your your funds
from coming in he's shutting down your
booking engines he's the one that's he's
doing that and Contin can you continue
continuing so he actually turned around
and weaponized that restraint in order
that the judge put on him to turn it
around on
and we will be looking forward to
getting your documentation of all of
this because this is the kind of stuff
that we need
not in a specific case mind you we can't
do that but to say whoa if this kind of
thing is happening and somebody else has
given us documentation maybe we got a
something that needs to be fixed here so
okay I've cut your mic off so if you
would uh if you have copies please give
them to the last one in the row and if
you don't have enough then you know
where we live
no you can't you're finished thank you
so if you got handouts
we got it we'll take them
and you use the a rainbow of such
beautiful paper as I recalled
I know
and while she's doing that
um we're going to call Robert tangway
you got five minutes
and you can start on this end
and you're going to need to turn the mic
back on
as I had killed it
boom
hello hello my name is Robert tanguin
I've spoken before this committee before
and I I do appreciate it
um I'd like to actually honor your work
um
The Honorable Miss gay uh for kind of
putting this together I've spoken with
the honorable uh Mr David Beckford
uh who drafted in 2005
uh was part of one of the drafters of
461a parental rights and
responsibilities which is very important
um I want to take this time
to kind of deflect
um some of what is going on especially
with the lady who spoke for 45 minutes
um with really any without any
unsubstantiated without any
substantiated evidence
um the courts are not the family Court's
specific are not working uh following
their rules one of the first rules in
first appearance is that
it must be before a judge in the family
court that is Rule 211. first appearance
that did not happen in my case and it
does not happen if you could hold up for
a minute I want to make sure this gets
into our record and we got a little
paper jam up here but I I'd like this
specific thing okay
so yeah we're stopping the clock yeah
I'm good that way I appreciate it okay
and we're going there we go okay so 211
first appearances in the family Rules
you guys need to read the family Rules
it's not that hard it's not that
complicated rules aren't magic you guys
know you guys know laws
um and that's what you do and uh it's a
very important part of the foundation of
our democracy and the reason why we're
not ripping each other apart
what's happening when the rules aren't
followed is that we're ripping each
other apart in family courts
so first appearance you must have a
hearing before a judge and you can read
I could read a word for word but
basically they're supposed to order
mediation
to prevent this and they're saying that
oh mediation is available in my specific
case a parenting uh petition was not
filed
uh until September of 2022
and then I went through the first
appearance
and then the domestic violence was filed
against me fictitiously uh to gain
strategic advantage in the court case to
preclude
mediation
to preclude it specifically because
that's the only way the court cannot
order mediation and it was done by a
lawyer see the lawyers are all in on it
together lawyers become judges and
there's tons of proof on that and you
can figure that out and that's what
we're having is an issue right now where
the lawyers are getting together to get
money from domestic violence they get
money from the state the lady who
testified earlier gets money from the
state
okay if you could suspend for a minute
I'm going to ask one of my Clerks
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
uh Mr Tanguay I just wanted to clarify
um so when was I I know you stated that
in September of 2022 a parenting plan
was filed when was your case first how
filed and when was the domestic violence
petition filed so they actually filed ex
parte on September
19th uh 2022
I roughly roughly we'll give that
roughly uh if it was at the beginning of
mid September
I did not hear about it until I filed
with the mother a demand letter
because I had grievances that's the
court in good faith you're supposed to
do that
November 30th a domestic violence
petition was filed after my
uh November 28th
motion with the court
to have them order mediation as they're
supposed to do
so they did that in direct response
does that answer your question yes thank
you thank you
um so that's just one example I guess
with the main point of my time that I
want to make is uh
the best course of action
to resolve because obviously family at
one time children were consider property
and so were women and uh that's
obviously important thing uh to
understand the not property but where
are they
173b is unconstitutional it needs to be
repealed it needs to be taken out of the
family courts the proper procedure is to
if you're a victim you're scared you
call the police the police need to do
their job the police are funded by local
municipalities
what is happening with 173b is we're
actually forcing the state to take on
this liability because every single
judge is a state employee and every
person in the court is a state employee
so my only restitution is not to go and
mess around with judicial review
committee and file complaints if you
read the Constitution is to sue the
state of New Hampshire
um another thing I wrote on every one of
those papers so what you're seeing is a
complaint with the Manchester Police
Department
and they've hired a lawyer and they're
not doing it it's still just refusing to
uh provide service I have no place to go
um
on top of that is Miller V Todd Miller V
Todd is a very famous case
um it's about parental alienation if you
do you know how I remembered it
I typed in Miller V finger's daughter NH
I'm sorry that's disgusting but that's
what I had to type in to remember
and in it eight years a father was
falsely accused of
molesting his children the children were
alienated they believed that they were
molested and there's a whole bunch of
case law about it but what we've found
is that
the mother and their parents basically
manipulated the children for eight years
and abused the children to take the
custody back and forth and it involves
the Manchester police
um for the last 30 seconds thank you sir
and I do appreciate it the last thing I
want to do is uh I want to read
uh
uh the orders which are false uh and
this should be criminal a penalty
this is what I was accused of this is
what the mathematical and physically
impossible statements initiated 1100
texts to Plaintiff in September 2022
same again in November in addition to 52
phone calls per puberty does include
numbers she refused to answer
he believes he has a constitutional
right to see his children morning and
night and this has hereby been found in
her home she refuses he refuses to exit
the car
after being asked to and was found
kneeling
and praying looking into a slider
the slider doesn't exist
okay wait until the Court's attention
15 seconds and then the mic goes away
yes sir I brought to the Court's
attention with three pleadings they
denied it that is with the police right
now the Manchester police
as orders I can't see my children I
can't see my children and so on so okay
thank you now it's on my dime uh could
you give a better a fuller reference for
Miller V Todd
uh Miller I think it's 2011.
um I don't have that I could send it to
you but you can just type in Miller Vito
what's that famous it's that famous it's
on the library the court Library website
and that the end result was that
alienation
is just as detrimental to the child's
welfare as the actual abuse itself and
this is the New Hampshire Supreme Court
so this is a New Hampshire case we're
circling around it and it looks like
2011. I bet that will be good any
questions for Mr tengue the chair
recognizes representative Smith thank
you just a quick question several times
you said that mediation is required
um can you give me the citation for that
uh yeah it's uh it it's in the family
court rules
that you can order it I don't know if
it's in 461a so that's very important
um but the only thing that precludes
that and I can provide that to the uh
committee is a filing a fighting of
domestic violence so 173b is
unconstitutional because what happens is
the process is someone writes a
complaint I I just I just I just needed
the answer to that question my
understanding is different but thank you
very much okay we'll check that out any
further questions of Mr tengue
uh none thank you so much for your
testimony and I am going to because I
know the one pink Carter it will be here
next week I'm going to now call Joseph
Nugent
yeah
no more no more this is and this is the
last person who will be called today
we've already gone well over 12.
because I'm a softy so go ahead Mr
duchins
and you're gonna thank you chairman and
committee for staying late to hear more
testimony today I've been precluded from
testifying before because there were too
many people in the time had been filled
up so I appreciate what you're doing
the outcome that we're I'm really hoping
for is that someone will investigate my
case in other cases going on in Carroll
County over the last number of years
from the Judiciary Committee
specifically that may take a closer look
at some of the things that are going on
in our County I think that you'll find
so many irregularities that will
justify your time in looking at some of
our cases specifically on my case
irregularities happened right at the
beginning of the case which was filed in
August of
2016. I was the petitioner on that case
uh later
I was accused of domestic violence and
that case was started
um by my son's mother in March of 2017.
I ex I requested expedited hearings and
if the committee would get the
transcripts from April 6th of 2017 and
then again from April 10th of 2017 I
think you'll see that what you're
hearing from the
uh interested parties that have
presented at the beginning of these
meetings is that we're not seeing a
rubber meets the road
action and what you're being told is
happening in the courts I think if you
read those two transcripts you'll be
very surprised at what you read
specifically you'll see that I was held
to a very specific standard of of
questioning that only a lawyer would be
able to know so we often hear that the
Rules of Evidence aren't applying but I
was not informed of direct questioning
indirect questioning cross-examination
but you'll see that I was held to a very
very specific standard in that case and
that began just a long laundry list of
abuses irregularities due process
violations please put me in all of those
files that you have I'm not sure unless
somebody is going to volunteer that we
will be getting those transcripts we
might suggest rather that you do because
if every person who testifies says you
guys got to go get the transcripts uh
I'm sorry I won't have time I thought
that's what you had said at the
organizational meetings that you would
be looking at over the summer I'm happy
to provide those for you thank you very
much and if I was confusing I apologize
for that that'll be very helpful because
it will be giving us specific
no problem I had previously mentioned in
the organizational meeting that what
happened in the hearing that day was
related to RSA 106 h14 as its relates to
9-1-1 calls right
so in that hearing
um specifically the DV hearing which was
held on April 10th I was not allowed to
use evidence to refute the allegations
made against me now that was allowed in
a later 20 months later
Superior Court case where I was charged
criminally and without the protection of
the trial by jury one of the few rights
that still stands in the state of New
Hampshire the government would have put
me in prison for three to seven years on
completely false allegations
did you see a difference between civil
court and Criminal Court in the way that
they handle that absolutely and that's
why I'm here to testify today in
confirming with Mr tangway that I have
felt that
uh the domestic violence RSA I believe
it's 173 B is unconstitutional I believe
that it's designed to take away all of
my constitutional rights aside from
quartering soldiers in my home it's
really designed to make it civil law
where someone can make accusations
against me but my understanding is that
civil law was meant to be a money
problem if you owe me five hundred
dollars we go to civil court not take my
child away from having a meaningful
relationship with my family his cousins
my 84 year old father his my nieces it
wasn't meant to be that way especially
for false allegations which are provable
is false because the 911
completion has still been withheld from
me and the irregularities and due
process violations in my case will show
you that despite numerous motions for
reconsideration and also appeals before
the Supreme Court the 9-1-1 call has
never been allowed to enter into
evidence in the family court or the
domestic violence case ever with
multiple pieces that you will all
receive in those motions it's horrendous
it's affecting and now next week an 11
year old child this has been going on
for six weeks six years and it's it's
impressing itself upon the chair and and
I would think others as well that if the
the penalty and I think loss of
fellowship with one's family members is
a heavy penalty it may not be called a
penalty but you're being penalized is of
such an order that some of the demands
and expenses of Criminal Court may need
to kick in
um in Criminal Court you've got people
doing all the investigating on the
state's dime in civil court you don't
and if you're going to have such an
outcome of this level then I could see a
case being made for this being treated
in some ways as if it was a criminal
issue with jury with investigators paid
for and so on I think I'm reflecting you
back am I
I think that there definitely needs to
be changed changed because the benches
for sale in New Hampshire and it's this
has reached a level of public corruption
this isn't just rule problems this this
9-1-1 call
being altered is really a criminal
matter well we're not going to be able
to go into that as a committee however
certainly we will look at whether there
seems to be some serious need for Rural
revision is there anyone who has a
question
uh of our testifier seeing none I want
to thank you for coming back and giving
us some more and we'll look for specific
details
and with that
um I adjourn half an hour late thank you
for people staying I've already got some
pink cards who will testify next week if
there's any more I'll take them until I
leave in about five minutes